I'm going in the far side. Yeah. You're in the middle? No. We're in the middle. No, we go how we're in the middle. Because it's your guest. Oh, and there's talking couches.
我要去最里面那一头。好吧。你坐中间？不。我们坐中间。不，我们要按怎么坐中间来，因为你是嘉宾。哦，还有会说话的沙发。
Yes. Yes. No, let me go out for the thing. What does that mean? We just can mess it. When we walk out. Yeah. I'm going to go far.
对。对。不，让我出去拿个东西。那是什么意思？我们只要走出去就能搞砸。好吧。我要坐得远一点。
I'm going to sit on the couch because it's my guest. Well, we can sit wherever you want. We can sit. Don't sit on the couch. No, we can sit. What doesn't matter? I've sat on the far side way too many times. OK.
我要坐在沙发上，因为我是嘉宾。好吧，你想坐哪儿就坐哪儿。我们可以坐。别坐在沙发上。不，我们可以坐。这有什么关系？我坐最里面那一头太多次了。好吧。
No, I'm sitting on the far side now, and you're going to be sitting on the near side. By the way, I had a tie iced tea, and it is not settling. But is the tea is a caffeine giving you energy? Because I feel like I need a little bit of energy. I know it worked out well for me and boxing. That works. I'm going to show you how hard I want you to slap me.
不，我这回要坐最里面那一头，你坐外面这一头。顺便说一句，我喝了一杯泰式冰茶，胃里有点难受。不过茶里的咖啡因能给你提神吗？因为我觉得我需要一点精神。我知道这在拳击上对我很管用。这招管用。我要让你看看我想让你多用力扇我。
OK, don't. OK. That worked. That, but don't, okay. That was for real. For real? Okay, here we go. I missed it entirely. Can you do the other side? Here we go.
好吧，别。好吧。管用了。那，但是别，好吧。那是来真的。真的吗？好了，我们开始吧。我完全打空了。你能换另一边吗？我们开始吧。
Here we go. Here we go. Welcome to your here end. All new is Smarlish! Smarlish! Smarlish! Smarlish! Smarlish!
我们开始吧。我们开始吧。欢迎来到你的……全新的 SmartLess！SmartLess！SmartLess！SmartLess！SmartLess！
Smarlish! Smarlish! Smarlish! Smarlish! Smarlish! Sharks. Sharks. Sharks. Sharks. Sharks. Sharks. Sharks. Sharks. Sharks. Sharks. Sharks.
SmartLess！SmartLess！SmartLess！SmartLess！SmartLess！鲨鱼。鲨鱼。鲨鱼。鲨鱼。鲨鱼。鲨鱼。鲨鱼。鲨鱼。鲨鱼。鲨鱼。鲨鱼。
Sharks. Sharks. Sharks. Sharks. Sharks. Sharks. Sharks. Sharks.
鲨鱼。鲨鱼。鲨鱼。鲨鱼。鲨鱼。鲨鱼。鲨鱼。鲨鱼。
Sharks. Sharks. A half a standing ovation. It's the greatest. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I think I have to beat Charles. Pete Charles, we beat each other for Rob Nader. Pete Soss, he got it. You guys, take a seat. So, Will's best friends get the best seat in the house.
鲨鱼。鲨鱼。半场起立鼓掌。这太棒了。我知道。我知道。我知道。我知道。我知道。我知道。我知道。我知道。我知道。我知道。我知道。我知道。我知道。我知道。我知道。我知道。我知道。我知道。我知道。我知道。我知道。我知道。我知道。我知道。我知道。我知道。我知道。我知道。我知道。我知道。我知道。我知道。我知道。我知道。我知道。我知道。我知道。我知道。我知道。我知道。我知道。我知道。我知道。我知道。我知道。我知道。我知道。我知道。我知道。我知道。我知道。我知道。我知道。我知道。我知道。我知道。我知道。我知道。我知道。我知道。我知道。我知道。我知道。我知道。我觉得我得打败查尔斯。皮特·查尔斯，我们为了罗布·内德尔互相殴打。皮特·索斯，他拿到了。各位，请坐。所以，威尔的好朋友坐全场最好的座位。
No, no. Rob, it didn't pay a dollar, right? This is a very LA crowd because we have the four best seats right here just empty. Just empty. Oh. Hello, Los Angeles! Hey!
不，不，罗布，这没花一美元，对吧？这是一个非常洛杉矶的观众群体，因为我们这里最好的四个座位全空着。全空着。哦。你好，洛杉矶！嘿！
Hey! We, uh, thank you for coming. We finally made it home. We made it home. We've been on the road. Yeah. We've taken this stupid ass, incredibly underwhelming night. Yeah.
嘿！我们，呃，谢谢你们的到来。我们终于到家了。我们到家了。我们在路上奔波。对。我们经历了这极其愚蠢、让人极其失望的一晚。对。
You guys are about to see on the road for a week. And we had a really, really good time. We want to keep setting the bars as low as possible for you all. So, let's get me to find out. So, we said let's sit down. Yeah, let's sit down. All right, so I'm on this side.
你们这群家伙要在路上看一个星期。我们度过了一段非常非常美好的时光。我们想为你们所有人把门槛设得尽可能低。所以，让我们找个人来了解一下。所以我们说坐下吧。对，坐下吧。好吧，那我坐这边。
You're there. You're on that side. We did. We did. We got applause for sitting. applause for sitting. We legit slapped each other backstage and that was not rehearsed and it actually hurt.
你坐那儿。你坐那边。我们做到了。我们做到了。我们坐下赢得了掌声。坐下赢得了掌声。我们在后台合法地互扇了耳光，而且那不是排练过的，其实还挺疼的。
Yeah, I put a little color in not rehearsed and it actually hurt. Yeah, I put a little color in my face though, and it's your face completely. But Sean, you got to heart out tonight, right? Because you got to get back to camp. Yeah, because you're dressed like a... LAUGHTER He's got his whistle in his pocket.
对，我脸上有点颜色，虽然没排练过，但确实挺疼的。对，我给自己的脸上加点颜色，把你的脸完全占了。不过肖恩，你今晚得赶回去，对吧？因为你得回训练营。对，因为你穿得像个……（笑声）他口袋里还装着哨子。
Yeah. And the other one is giving a high-fives. Oh, no. LAUGHTER You look very, very cute. I look very cute. You do look like, which is very scary for a 51-year-old. Yeah.
对。另一个在击掌。哦，不。（笑声）你看起来非常非常可爱。我看起来很可爱。你确实看起来像，这对于一个51岁的人来说非常可怕。对。
No, you look, it looks like this looks like Sunday afternoon at your house. Well, it's what we all do, kind of. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Oh, by the way, I'm chewing gum. I'm sorry, and by the way, they ever put gum in water and it flavors the water. Wow. But how do you guys feel?
不，你看起来，这看起来像你家周日的下午。嗯，这差不多是我们所有人都会做的事。对，对，对。哦，顺便说一句，我在嚼口香糖。不好意思，顺便说一句，他们有没有把口香糖放进水里给水调味。哇。不过你们感觉怎么样？
Are you guys tired from the tour? Are you pumped? Well, they, you guys give us energy. Yeah, we legit can't believe that you guys listen to the podcast. That's true. That's really been a mind-blower. So first of all, thank you for doing that because all we're doing as you can tell,
你们巡演累了吗？你们兴奋吗？嗯，他们，你们给了我们能量。对，我们简直不敢相信你们会听这个播客。真的。这真的让人大开眼界。所以首先，谢谢你们这么做，因为正如你们所见，我们一直在做的事，
if we just talk to each other, the fact that people are somewhat interested in listening to that is a mind-blower, we do feel like since you can fast forward all the crap parts or just go to a different episode when you're listening to the podcast, here you're trapped. So we feel like we do have to juice it a little bit. So do you feel like people maybe double time, like double speed your questions?
如果我们只是自言自语，居然会有人对听这个感兴趣，这真是太让人大开眼界了。我们确实觉得，既然你们听播客时可以快进掉所有垃圾部分，或者直接跳到另一集，但在这里你们被困住了。所以我们觉得我们必须给它加点料。那么你们觉得大家会不会开倍速，比如两倍速听你们的问题？
They have to. Because that's a great, yeah. That's a really good, smart-less hack. I'm gonna give you guys a lot of smart-less hacks. They did laugh, and applaud, like, you know, exactly what you're talking about. I was trying to think of like a good LA story, like when I first moved here.
他们肯定会。因为这是一个绝妙的，对。这真的是一个很好的 SmartLess 绝招。我要给你们很多 SmartLess 绝招。他们确实笑了，也鼓掌了，就像，你知道的，正如你们所说的那样。我在想一个好的洛杉矶故事，比如我刚搬来这里的时候。
Oh, settle in, everybody. Oh. Somebody's prepped a little bit. So, I was just before I started. Does it involve the 101? Boy, traffic is terrible. Oh, God. No, let's just single up a spot on Sean and take front seat. No, I may have said the story before, but when I first moved here and I got Will and Grace, I went to a cashier.
哦，大家都坐好。哦。有人提前做过功课了。所以，我刚才开始之前。这跟101号公路有关吗？天哪，交通太糟糕了。哦，天哪。不，让我们直接把焦点对准肖恩，让他坐前排。不，我可能以前讲过这个故事，但当我刚搬到这里并参演《威尔与格蕾丝》时，我去找了一个出纳员。
Hold your hands. No, I didn't have two nickels rubbed together. I had no money. And the cast and the producers invited us out to a dinner. So I drove my Toyota Corolla, which had a hubcap missing and a window out with the plastic. Yeah, plastic and duct tape. Yes, absolutely, 100%.
举起你们的手。不，我身上连两个硬币都凑不齐。我一分钱也没有。然后剧组和制片人邀请我们去吃晚餐。所以我开着我的丰田花冠，它少了一个轮毂盖，一个窗户破了用塑料布挡着。对，塑料布和大力胶带。是的，绝对，100%。
Come on. I swear to God. And so I drove. Is that the car you drove from Chicago? Yes, it is. Yes, and it broke down in Colorado. And I paid some guy, I don't even know money to fix it. And it was still broke down.
得了吧。我发誓。所以我开车去的。那是你从芝加哥开过来的车吗？是的，没错。是的，它还在科罗拉多州抛锚了。我付给某个家伙，我甚至不知道多少钱让他修车。结果它还是抛锚了。
A mechanic, hopefully. I don't know. And so, it's just some guy on the road. So I'm driving, I'm sorry. So I get to the restaurant extra early, because I'm so nervous about, you know, them seeing my car and my car and I'm broke and anyway. So I got there.
希望是个机械师。我不知道。所以，就是路上随便一个家伙。所以我开着车，对不起。所以我超额提前到达了餐馆，因为我太紧张了，你知道的，他们看到我的车，看到我破产了，反正。所以我到了。
Oh, you were embarrassed about. I was embarrassed about my car because it was like, we pieced together with Scotch tape. So I got it, I got there, I went in and then before the dinner was over, I kind of left early so that I could get my car from the valet. And leave before they can see me. So I'm like, bye, everybody, oh my God, I'm so excited.
哦，你对……感到尴尬。我对我的车感到尴尬，因为它就像是用苏格兰胶带拼凑起来的。所以我到了，我进去了，然后在晚宴结束前，我提前离开了，这样我就可以去代客泊车那里拿我的车。并在他们看到我之前离开。所以我就像，再见，大家，哦天哪，我太激动了。
I come out to the valet and I'm standing there and then Jimmy Burrows, Debra, Megan, Eric, the producers, a couple of writers. And now we're all standing there and I'm like, oh my God. And so he pulls the car up and I was like, and it's like barely getting there. So the last sub-tap rolls off. Right, and I said to everybody, I said to the Valet,
我走到代客泊车那里站在那儿，然后吉米·伯勒斯、黛布拉、梅根、埃里克、制片人、几个编剧。现在我们都站在那儿，我想，哦天哪。然后他把车开过来，我想，而且车勉强才开到。最后一个轮毂盖滚了下来。对，我对大家说，我对代客泊车说，
I go, what did you do to my car? Oh my God. I said to the ballet, I go, what did you do to my car? LAUGHTER Oh my god. First of all, I was a Porsche, now it's not a Porsche anymore. Now, ironically, you did end up getting a Porsche when the show performed. Yes, everybody had Porsche on the show, right? Right, that's also embarrassing, but I also didn't have money
我说，你对我的车做了什么？哦天哪。我对代客泊车说，我问你对我的车做了什么？（笑声）哦天哪。首先，我以前开的是保时捷，现在它不再是保时捷了。现在，讽刺的是，当节目成功后，你确实得到了一辆保时捷。是的，节目里的每个人都有一辆保时捷，对吧？对，这也挺尴尬的，但我也没有钱，
when they gave me a Porsche, I'm like, give me the fucking money, I don't want to need another car for. Yeah. But it was very, very kind of them. But when you were struggling, actor, and you did it. So you sold it, right? Absolutely, right away. Yeah.
当他们给我一辆保时捷时，我说，给我该死的钱吧，我不需要另一辆车。对。但他们真的非常非常善良。但当你是个苦苦挣扎的演员时，你确实这么做了。所以你把它卖了，对吧？绝对的，马上就卖了。对。
I had to pay my rent. I had my rent. I had to pay my rent. Relax, it was a boxer. But the point is, it's true. Why did you drive it? Or did you sell it? I just, I read the details on that story years ago.
我得付房租。我有房租要交。我得付房租。放松点，那是一辆保时捷。但重点是，这是真的。你为什么开着它？还是你把它卖了？我只是，我几年前读过那个故事的细节。
And that always stuck with me. I was like, oh, they give them porcises. Oh, did you drive it or did you know? I just I read the details on that story years ago. And that always stuck with me. Yeah. I was like, oh, they give them porcises. Oh, did they? Yeah. I know it seems knobby, but it's kind of true. Yeah.
那件事一直印在我脑海里。我想，哦，他们送他们保时捷。哦，你是开着它还是你知道？我只是，我几年前读过那个故事的细节。那件事一直印在我脑海里。对。我想，哦，他们送他们保时捷。哦，是吗？对。我知道这看起来很势利，但确实如此。对。
What about your first time out here? Do you remember? Yeah, I was talking about today. I drove out here as well. I drove. I had an old... Did they not have planes back then? Yeah. No.
你第一次来这里是什么时候？你还记得吗？对，我今天还在说这个。我也是开车来这里的。我开着车。我有一辆旧的……他们那时候没有飞机吗？对。没有。
No. It was so funny. And from Toronto, you couldn't have a longer drive. No, no, I drove from New York, because I was living in New York. Oh, New York is much closer. Yeah, so it's much... Yeah.
没有。太搞笑了。从多伦多出发，不可能有更长的车程了。不，不，我是从纽约开过来的，因为我当时住在纽约。哦，纽约近得多。对，所以它更……对。
In fact, it's further away. That's true. But yeah, I drove. I had this old Volvo station wagon and I we drove out here I don't know why we made a trip. I love a Volvo station wagon. Yeah, I right It was it was a real piece of shit and it had it had it arrested through on the bottom and you could see the road underneath Like like Fred Fred for the stone. Yeah, like for the stone. It was it was that bad But it was it was a ton of fun and then I drove back ended, I ended up driving Vex in New York a couple months later.
事实上，它更远。确实如此。但对，我开车来的。我有一辆旧的沃尔夫松（沃尔沃）旅行车，我们开车来到这里，我不知道为什么我们要进行一次旅行。我喜欢沃尔沃旅行车。对，没错，它真的是个烂透了的破车，它底部都生锈了，你能看到地面的路面，就像……就像摩登原始人里那样。对，就像摩登原始人。它就是那么糟。但它真的超级好玩，然后我又开车开回……几个月后我又开车把车开回了纽约。
And same car. Same car in like 40 hours straight. And that's the way to do it. To stop is like, no, you blirry eyed, you gotta keep going. No, and then I had somebody else with me, and I would sleep in the back, and he would drive, and then we would sleep like this.
还是同一辆车。同一辆车，连续开了大约40个小时。这才叫开车。停下来就像是，不，你眼睛都花了，你得继续开。不，然后我还有个人陪着我，我睡在后座，他开车，然后我们这样睡觉。
That's what it looked like, for Randy, yeah. And my car was packed to the end, and I would get into the passenger seat, and I would go down on the bucket, and would sleep on the thing because there was no room. There was no room. Show us how you sleep again, really quick. Yeah. Sure.
兰迪当时就是那个样子，对。我的车塞得满满当当，我就坐进副驾驶座，我把座位调到最低，然后睡在那个东西上，因为根本没地方。根本没地方。再给我们演示一下你是怎么睡觉的，快点。好。当然。
It's like that. What? Hang on. Yeah. What? Wait, you sleep more comfortably in a car if you get down into the footwell? Yes! Yes, because you can't sleep like a purple cat.
就像那样。什么？等等。对。什么？等等，如果你缩进脚坑里，你在车里睡得更舒服？是的！是的，因为你不能像一只紫色的猫那样睡觉。
Sure you can. Yeah, I'm not a cow. How do you do it on a plane, guy? I go back, dude. You don't get on the floor on the plane? That would be so great if you got on the floor on the plane. I mean, it's not just in throw eccentric on a plane. You guys hear this story of the podcast?
你当然可以。对，我又不是牛。伙计，你在飞机上是怎么睡的？我往后靠，老兄。你在飞机上不会钻到地板上吧？如果你在飞机上钻到地板上那就太棒了。我的意思是，这在飞机上不仅仅是古怪。你们听过播客里的这个故事吗？
We got to do it for a second. Do we already tell those who have it? They already know it. They already know it, you know? Yeah, but we let's embarrass them further. No, no, no, no. He deserves to be embarrassed about this. Just to throw a can't sleep with shirt on, right?
我们得讲一分钟。我们是不是已经讲过那些有这个经历的人了？他们已经知道了。他们早就知道了，你知道吗？对，但我们要让他们更尴尬。不，不，不，不。他活该为此感到尴尬。只是扔掉一件不能穿着睡觉的衬衫，对吧？
I mean, I'm sure a lot of people sleep without their shirt on, right? And he can't sleep without a shirt on, and he can't sleep without doing crunches before he goes to sleep. Right, right. I don't know this story. I don't know this story.
我的意思是，我确信很多人睡觉时不穿衬衫，对吧？而他不能不穿衬衫睡觉，而且他睡觉前不做好几组卷腹就睡不着。对，对。我不知道这个故事。我不知道这个故事。
So we're flying to England, I think. So it's going to be topless for quite a stretch. Yeah. And he's all tatted up and he's up front and everything. Where people are wearing ties and stuff. And he just pops his shirt off. He does a perfunctory cover with a little tiny blanket or whatever.
所以我们正飞往英国，我想。所以有一大段时间他都要光着膀子。对。而且他浑身都是纹身，他坐在前排什么的。到处都是系着领带的人。他直接把衬衫脱了。他敷衍了事地盖上一条小毯子什么的。
But five minutes into that, that's gone. And it's just some tatted up freak who looks like Iggy Pop. She has passed out in the front. It's like really? I'm afraid I need to wipe everything down. I could never sleep with my shirt off. It's disgusting. That's right.
但仅仅过了五分钟，毯子就没了。只有一个看起来像伊基·波普、满身纹身的怪胎在前排昏睡过去。真的吗？我恐怕得把所有东西都擦一遍。我绝对不可能光着膀子睡觉。太恶心了。没错。
He's got a layer to protect him from the germs. He's got a layer of spray tan that actually keeps the germs. But you will get down on the floor well of a car and sleep. Those germs are okay. Absolutely. At 24 years old. Yeah. Oh my God.
他有一层保护膜来抵御细菌。他有一层喷雾美黑液，实际上能阻挡细菌。但你却会钻进汽车的脚坑里睡觉。那些细菌就没问题。绝对没问题。在24岁的时候。对。哦，天哪。
Wow. Let's get a guest. Alright, let's get a guest out here. Let's get a guest out here. It's Jason's guest. So we don't know who is. And by the way, just in case people don't know, and we say it all the time, we legitimately
哇。让我们请个嘉宾吧。好吧，我们请个嘉宾上台吧。我们请个嘉宾上台吧。这是杰森的嘉宾。所以我们不知道是谁。顺便说一句，以防大家不知道，我们经常说，我们真的
don't know who the other person's guess are. So we've had to jump through a lot of hoops on this tour to, like, not cross paths with the guests. Yeah, we had a great one. Never mind. Okay, go ahead. What? What?
不知道对方的嘉宾是谁。所以我们在这次巡演中费尽周折，比如不和嘉宾撞车。对，我们有一个很棒的……算了。好吧，继续。什么？什么？
What? There. Oh, no, Jason, it's okay. But I have not learned my lesson because when's the last time you guys met a real bullfighter? Oh, no, I'm kidding. I'm kidding. I'm kidding. I could have been so cruel. I would love that. I would love that.
什么？在那儿。哦，不，杰森，没关系。但我还没吸取教训，因为你们上一次见到真正的斗牛士是什么时候？哦，不，我开玩笑的。我开玩笑的。我开玩笑的。我本可以那么残忍的。我会喜欢那样的。我会喜欢那样的。
I would love it too. I would have a thousand questions for that. I would love it too if we were going to cover this, but they don't want that to. To a backstage, you'd love it. Here we come. Our guest tonight is a force, a comedic fire hose. Right?
我也希望如此。如果我们要报道这个的话，我会有一千个问题要问。如果我们去后台的话，我也会喜欢那样的。我们来吧。今晚的嘉宾是个狠角色，一个喜剧喷射器。对吧？
It's a good start, right? Not a bullfighter. Very no, very good. This man can't be contained. His energy and positivity is infectious, y'all. Philadelphia couldn't hold him New York seasoned him. And now, lucky for us, he's planted out here in LA, pumping out Project After Project for all of us to gobble up.
这是个好的开始，对吧？不是斗牛士。非常不，非常好。这个人无法被压制。他的精力和积极性极具感染力，各位。费城留不住他，纽约磨炼了他。现在，幸运的是，他在洛杉矶扎了根，为我们所有人源源不断地推出一个又一个项目。
He's done tons of movies, TV shows released multiple comedy albums and specials. He's got 45 nominations from everything. We're emmies to Grammys. He's got a freaking video game, I think, somehow though. He's been nice enough to pull it over to the side, give us a little time for Chatton Giggle here on the Smiley's couch, gang!
他拍过无数电影、电视节目，发行了多张喜剧专辑和特辑。他获得了45个奖项的提名，从艾美奖到格莱美奖。我想他不知怎么的还搞出了一个该死的电子游戏。他非常友善地停下来，抽点时间在我们 SmartLess 的沙发上和我们聊天嬉闹，各位！
Buckle up, it's the one and only Kevin Hart. Oh! Oh! Oh, my God. Woo! Oh, my God. I love you, man. I love you. Well.
系好安全带，这就是独一无二的凯文·哈特！哦！哦！哦，天哪。呜！哦，天哪。我爱你，老兄。我爱你。好吧。
Man, I can't wait. He only moved. Oh, that's good. Hello, hello, hello. Kevin Hart. It's so cool, Jack. Am I on? By the way, you know what that is? That's redemption.
老兄，我等不及了。他刚搬来。哦，那太好了。哈喽，哈喽，哈喽。凯文·哈特。太酷了，杰克。我开麦了吗？顺便说一句，你知道那是什么吗？那是救赎。
That is redemption. That is an over-deliver. And I'm over-deliver. Check, check. Can you hear me? Yeah. Yeah, we got you. All right.
那是救赎。那是超额完成任务。我是超额完成。检查，检查。听得到我说话吗？对。对，我们听得到。好吧。
Wait. Well, before you... What? I just want you... I want you guys to lower your expectations because I've been drinking. So I just... Slow, lower them down.
等等。好吧，在你……什么？我只是想让你……我想让你们降低期望，因为我已经喝了酒。所以我只是……放慢点，把期望降下来。
That's fair, fair warning. It's the gallon. Whoa, wow. Is it really? Good for you. That's cool for you. Superbowl we get. It smells real good.
这很公平，善意的警告。是一加仑。哇，哇。真的是吗？真为你高兴。这对你来说挺酷的。我们有超级碗。闻起来真香。
And then behind there is just a chest full of weed, right? It's a shit. It's good for you. We're not paying him for this. Is he mad? Yes, he's mad. Here we go. No, it's not.
然后在它后面是一个装满大麻的箱子，对吧？太扯了。真为你高兴。我们可没付他钱让他说这个。他生气了吗？是的，他生气了。我们开始吧。不对。
What's your fucking problem? Yeah! She's fucking fast. This is his fourth gig today. He's in the bag. It's Shunzen Church of Blocking. Yeah, he's just... He really just... Wait.
你他妈的有什么毛病？耶！她他妈的好快。这是他今天的第四场演出。他喝醉了。这是舜镇阻击教堂。对，他只是……他真的只是……等等。
He really is pushing me back. Get the fuck back. All right. By the way, I'm such a huge fan. You've been on my list to come on as well, but I can't believe Jason and Ab Jop. I'm a massive fan. Did he turn you down? He said OK. Absolutely. I'm a massive fan. Did he turn you down?
他真的在把我往回推。滚开。好吧。顺便说一句，我是你的超级粉丝。你也一直在我的邀请名单上，但我简直不敢相信杰森和阿布·乔普。我是你的狂热粉丝。他拒绝过你吗？他说可以。绝对的。我是个狂热粉丝。他拒绝过你吗？
He said okay. Absolutely. I'm a big fan. I'm a big fan of Bateman. You know what? I didn't tell you what. I bum rush Kevin when we were doing we did a different stroke. Oh no not not you were doing different.
他说可以。绝对的。我是贝特曼的超级粉丝。你知道吗？我没告诉你。当我门突袭凯文时，我们正在拍……我们拍过不同的剧集。哦不，不是……你拍的不是不同的剧集。
I had these different strokes. You did that to life. Yeah that's right. For our buddy Jimmy Kimmel does this. Why do you have to count? Whatever the hell it is. he doesn't know what the hell it is you don't know what he does we did it he does a pretty handsome talk show but he did it we do reduce of episodes
我有这些不同的剧集。你那是对生活的。对，没错。为了我们的老友吉米·坎摩尔做的这个。你为什么非要数数？不管那是什么鬼东西。他根本不知道那是什么鬼东西，你也不知道他在做什么，我们拍了，他做了一个相当帅气的脱口秀，但他做到了，我们重拍了情景喜剧的剧集
of sitcoms we did facts life you played Arnold on different strokes it was so killed it yes so I cornered him and you really didn't have a chance to say no, I apologize. No, you didn't corner me. Look, you're in the group of guys that don't ask for shit.
我们拍了《糊涂妙探》（事实生活），你在《不同 Strokes》里演了阿诺德，太棒了，是的，所以我把他逼到墙角，你真的没有机会说不，我道歉。不，你没有把我逼到墙角。听着，你属于那种平时不要求什么的家伙。
I feel like there's a certain amount of people in our business that don't ask, that when they do ask, it's like, yeah, I'll do it because they don't ask. So those people that don't ask normally have something that's good when they do ask. So, Bateman asked, and I'll be honest, I'll be honest, and this is only for you guys, I thought it was Ozark. I thought I was, I did, I swear to God. I swear to God, I thought it was a scene in Ozark. I can't, and I, I found out.
我觉得我们这个行业里有一部分人从不求人，而当他们开口时，就会觉得，好吧，我做，因为他们平时不求人。所以那些平时不求人的人，在他们开口时通常都有好东西。所以，贝特曼开口了，说实话，我实话实说，这只对你们说，我以为那是《黑钱胜地》。我以为我是，我当时真的，我发誓。我发誓，我以为那是《黑钱胜地》里的一场戏。我不能，我……我刚刚才发现。
You know what we can do is we can make the light blue if you like. No, no, it's okay. I just found out just now this isn't Ozark when it was alive. It would be a very special dream sequence. Call him Marty for the rest. Let's just keep calling him Marty. Um, um, um, a payback is gonna be tough isn't it.
你知道我们可以怎么做，如果你喜欢的话，我们可以把灯光变成蓝色。不，不，没关系。我刚刚才发现这不是《黑钱胜地》，当它……这将是一个非常特别的梦境。剩下的时间都叫他马蒂吧。我们以后就叫他马蒂。嗯，嗯，嗯，复仇会很难，对吧？
What are you gonna ask me to do? Uh, I don't know. Jason, here's the weird thing, man. You don't want me to do anything. Here one don't know. Jason, here's the weird thing, man. You don't want me to do anything. Here, one of those guys is talented, but then you're like, eh, like, you know, what are you? It's like, it's like, what are you? That's a...
你打算让我做什么？呃，我不知道。杰森，奇怪的地方就在这里，老兄。你根本不想让我做任何事。这里有个家伙很有才华，但然后你会觉得，呃，你知道的，你到底算什么？就像是，就像是，你到底算什么？那是……
What do you really want from them? Right? No, on a serious note, Jason Bateman, to me, is Hollywood royalty. That is finished. By the way. Yes, I agree. By the way, here's what I mean when I say that.
你到底想从他们身上得到什么？对吧？不，说正经的，杰森·贝特曼在我眼里就是好莱坞皇室。那是没话说的。顺便说一句。是的，我同意。顺便说一句，我这么说是什么意思呢？
Hollywood royalty. That's a typical definition. Will falls in his category too. Sean. Well, I don't. Sean, I'm not sure what you. Shouldn't have pushed him, Sean. I know.
好莱坞皇室。这是一个典型的定义。威尔也属于这一类。肖恩。嗯，我不是。肖恩，我不确定你……你不该推他的，肖恩。我知道。
Shouldn't have pushed him. Sean, if you didn't push me, I would have done my research. But, all right. Hollywood royalty to me is people that work consistently, consistently without an agenda, people that do what they want, and have a good time in doing it. Royalty.
不该推他的。肖恩，如果你不推我，我就会去做我的研究了。但是，好吧。在我看来，好莱坞皇室是指那些始终如一、毫无私心地努力工作的人，是那些做自己想做的事并且乐在其中的人。皇室。
Royalty. That's fucking a little bit of a Royalty. Yes, but I'm saying that's why I respect that. Thank you. Congratulations, you guys. Thank you. Hey! Hey, you got nominated for an interviewer of the year
皇室。这他妈的有点像皇室。是的，但我说的是，这就是我尊重这一点的原因。谢谢。恭喜你们，各位。谢谢。嘿！嘿，你获得了年度采访者的提名，
that should be good enough. Right? No. You guys, you guys, wait, you guys, you guys are the royalty. And I'm the jester. You are the best camp counselor out of all four of us. So he's not the guy responsible for blocking? No, he's the tonight's No. All right, well,
这应该就足够好了。对吧？没有。你们，你们，等等，你们，你们才是皇室。而我是小丑。你们四个里，你是最好的营地辅导员。所以他不是负责阻挡的那个人？不，他不是今晚的……不。好吧，
pound to you, buddy. I know what you do now. Fuck yeah. All right. Now, so this is this is very a foreign to us, but you have spent a lot of time in front of audiences doing stand-up, doing specials. Yeah. You had you played in front of 55,000 people? Yeah, don't forget to tell us. Thank you guys. This is intimate. This is nice. Yeah. It's a very nice intimate crowd, man.
向你致敬，老兄。我现在知道你是干什么的了。他妈的太棒了。好了。所以，这对我来说非常陌生，但你花了很多时间在观众面前进行单口喜剧表演，做特辑。对。你在55,000人面前表演过？对，别忘了告诉我们。谢谢你们。这很亲密。这感觉真好。对。这是一个非常好的亲密观众群体，老兄。
This is what it's about. How? It's about connecting with the people. Yeah. Here's what blows my mind. Here's what blows my mind. By the way, I'm a huge shark tank fan. And I saw you on Shark Tank, and I was blown away.
这才是最重要的。关于与人连接。对。下面是让我大开眼界的地方。下面是让我大开眼界的地方。顺便说一句，我是《创智赢家》的超级粉丝。我在《创智赢家》上看到你时，我惊呆了。
Thank you, man. I had no idea. I mean, I knew you had a lot of fun. Is that black? What the fuck are you saying? Hey. What are you saying? Yeah, so what were you on charting for? Were you pitching something or judging?
谢谢你，老兄。我完全不知道。我的意思是，我知道你玩得很开心。那是黑色的吗？你他妈在说什么？嘿。你在说什么？对，那你上《创智赢家》是去推销什么还是当评委？
No, no. The fuck is that? I'm not seeing the show. No, but I have a big start. He was a shark. He was a shark. He was a shark. He was a shark.
不，不。那是什么鬼？我没看过那个节目。不，但我有一个很大的开始。他是个鲨鱼。他是个鲨鱼。他是个鲨鱼。他是个鲨鱼。
You were pitching like, I got an idea? I don't know. No, no, no, no, Jay. He was like Mark Cuban, but a guest show. You were pitching like, I got an idea? I don't know. No, no, no, no, Chase. He was like Mark Cuban, but a guest. Okay, but I'm Kevin Hart, bitch. But I got my new name. What, he, am I pitching an idea? What, hang on.
你是去推销像“我有个主意”这样的东西吗？我不知道。不，不，不，不，杰。他就像马克·库班，但作为客串。你是去推销像“我有个主意”这样的东西吗？我不知道。不，不，不，不，蔡斯。他就像马克·库班，但作为客串。好吧，但我可是凯文·哈特，碧池。但我有了新名字。什么，他，我是去推销一个主意吗？什么，等等。
If I've got some great idea for the new swifter or something, I don't wanna fund that. I want Mark Cuban to fund that. So I'm gonna go on the show, I'm gonna pitch him. Regardless of what I got in the bank, I want to hit you. You got more. That's stupid, because you can just call Mark Cuban.
如果我对新的拖把有什么好主意，我才不想让它融资呢。我想让马克·库班为它融资。所以我会上节目，我去向他推销。不管我银行里有多少钱，我都想打击你。你有更多。这太蠢了，因为你直接给马克·库班打电话就行了。
Yeah. If you go on massive television. If you go on massive television. I'm sure I've built an extra step there. That's right. But I always knew you had all these things going on, but I just didn't know at that extent. I mean, you have this huge successful company
对。如果你上大型电视节目。如果你上大型电视节目。我确信我在那里多走了一步。没错。但我一直知道你有很多项目在进行，只是我不知道规模有这么大。我的意思是，你有一个规模庞大、非常成功的公司，
that makes all of these projects and these things come to life. I just had no idea. And on top of that, you invest in tons of things. Some of them I do too. So we're kind of messed up. Yeah. It's a secret to the success. But I think building up a
它让所有这些项目和事情都变为现实。我完全不知道。最重要的是，你投资了无数的东西。其中有些我也投了。所以我们有点混在一起了。对。这就是成功的秘诀。但我认为建立一个
platform and infrastructure with people that are so talented, so amazing, to help me execute things that I have a vision for, have become my priority in the business. And also identifying people, maybe that might need a little help for access, and you kind of grandfathered that maybe a little bit. You bring people into your company. I do, you know, I really do. I think it's no longer about me, it's not about my stars, it's not about where I am, it's not about helping others.
拥有如此多才华横溢、令人惊叹的人才的平台和基础设施，来帮助我执行我有愿景的事情，已经成为我在这行中的首要任务。还有识别那些可能需要一点获取帮助的人，你可能有点像祖父一样照顾他们。你把人才引进你的公司。是的，你知道，我真的会的。我认为这不再关乎我自己，不关乎我的明星身份，不关乎我身在何处，而是关乎帮助他人。
And the real benefit, it's true. Yeah, it's true. That's why I do this podcast to help these guys out. That's the way I do it. Good for you, well. Now, with all of that work though, do you, are you good about taking breaks, whether it be at home or like fun vacations?
真正的益处，确实如此。对，确实如此。这就是为什么我做这个播客来帮助这几个家伙。这就是我做这件事的方式。真有你的，威尔。现在，尽管有这么多的工作，你，你擅长休息吗？无论是在家里还是去有趣的度假？
What's your work? This, this is a break. I'm taking a break now. That said, I don't wanna do something good, right? Let me come. Yeah, yeah. And like, I have a problem in here.
你的工作是什么？这，这就是休息。我现在就在休息。也就是说，我不想做点好事，对吧？让我来。对，对。就像，我这里有个问题。
I think it's a problem, right? Just get it, no, I'm joking. On some real shit like I have a tough time doing that have a tough time taking breaks I have a tough time really taking time to myself and that's what I'm working on So if I had to say a flaw a flaw is realizing that I need downtime Like just to take your foot off the gas a little bit Yeah, so Kevin we first met over 20 years ago. You were a stand-up. What? It's the truth.
我觉得这是个问题，对吧？算了吧，不，我开玩笑的。说真的，我很难做到这一点，我很难抽出时间休息，我很难真正花时间给自己放个假，而这正是我正在努力改进的。所以如果非要说一个缺点，一个缺点就是意识到我需要停工休息，就像稍微把脚从油门上拿开一点一样。对，凯文，我们第一次见面是在20年多前。你当时是个单口喜剧演员。什么？这是真的。
It's true. It was true. And you were a stand-up, but you were just breaking through. Like, obviously, you didn't have the success that you have now. Walk us through a little bit those first, because I remember those first couple of years, you did that pilot with a bunch of our friends. And then that pilot didn't get picked up,
千真万确。这是真的。你当时是个单口喜剧演员，但你正处于崭露头角的阶段。很显然，你当时还没有现在这样的成功。跟我们聊聊那最初的几年吧，因为我记得那最初的几年，你和我们的一群朋友拍了那个试播集。然后那个试播集没有被选中，
and then you seemed like you did a pilot every year. You'd always be at the up-fronts, which is where they sell the ads for new shows. For Tracy, yeah. You were always like, yeah, for Tracy. By the way, we had Tracy. You were at Tracy? Sean's sister.
然后你好像每年都要拍一个试播集。你总是出现在 Upfronts（电视推介会）上，那是他们为新节目推销广告的地方。为了特雷西，对。你总是说，为了特雷西。顺便说一句，我们请到了特雷西。你在特雷西那儿？肖恩的妹妹。
We went to Wisconsin, and she came on stage, and it was fucking... All Front Row T-shirts said, I know Tracy or... He was talking rad, man. It was so rad. Because we thought she was fake. But anyway- And by the way, it didn't look half as dumb
我们去了威斯康星州，她上了台，那真是他妈的……所有前排的T恤上都写着“我认识特雷西”或者……他当时说话很酷，老兄。太酷了。因为我们以为她是假的。但无论如何——顺便说一句，看起来一点也不像肖恩让你听起来那么蠢。
as Sean makes you sound. No. Like, what are you doing? She was kind of more with it than you, dude. Yeah. I get it. And we will be right back. This episode is brought to you in part by 8Sleep.
不。就像你在干什么？她比你更懂行，老兄。对。我懂的。我们马上回来。本集部分内容由 8 Sleep 赞助播出。
Did you know that temperature is one of the most important factors in improving your sleep quality? When you wake up in the middle of the night or feel extra groggy in the morning, temperature is usually the one to blame. The pod cover by 8Sleep fits on any bed like a fitted sheet and will improve your sleep by automatically adjusting the temperature on each side of the bed based on you and your partner's individual needs. So for me, in our apartment, our thermostat is crazy. Like, there's one zone in our apartment, in our small apartment, that services three rooms, right? So it clicks on cold in the middle of the night, then it shuts off to then click
你知道温度是改善睡眠质量最重要的因素之一吗？当你半夜醒来或者早上感觉格外疲惫时，通常都是温度惹的祸。8 Sleep 的 Pod 床罩可以像床单一样套在任何床垫上，通过根据你和伴侣各自的需求自动调节床两侧的温度，来改善你的睡眠。所以对我和我公寓来说，我们的恒温器太疯狂了。比如，我们公寓里有一个区域，在我们的小公寓里，要服务三个房间，对吧？所以它会在半夜突然变冷，然后关闭，接着又为另一个房间开启
on cold for another room. And while it's cooling down in another room, it gets hot again. Anyway, the point is the temperature in my room here in New York in my apartment is whacked. And I got the pod cover by eight sleep and I'm sleeping like a king again. And I love the pod cover and I love that we're talking about it on the podcast. Thanks to the pods, sleep and health tracking, you can wake up to a personalized sleep report for you each morning that offers insights
制冷。当另一个房间在降温时，它又变热了。总之，重点是我在纽约的公寓里，我房间里的温度简直一团糟。但我有了 8 Sleep 的 Pod 床罩，我又像国王一样入睡了。我喜欢 Pod 床罩，我也喜欢我们在播客里谈论它。多亏了 Pod 的睡眠和健康追踪功能，你每天早晨都可以醒来看到一份专属的睡眠报告，里面提供了
in how certain behaviors like late night exercise or caffeine or whatever it is, impact your sleep and overall health. Invest in the rest you deserve with the eight-sleep pod. Go to eightsleep.com slash smartless and save $150 on the pod cover by 8-Sleep. That's the best offer you'll find, but you must visit 8sleep.com slash smartless
关于你的某些行为（如深夜锻炼、咖啡因或无论什么）如何影响你的睡眠和整体健康的见解。投资于你应得的休息，购买 8 Sleep Pod。访问 eightsleep.com/smartless，购买 8 Sleep Pod 床罩即可节省 150 美元。这是你能找到的最优惠价格，但你必须访问 eightsleep.com/smartless
for $150 off. 8-Sleep currently ships within the USA, Canada, the UK select countries in the EU and Australia. I'm not afraid to tell you, we get support from Audible, okay? It's the home of storytelling. Now I'm not, you know, a great reader, okay? I've for a bunch of reasons that I'm not going to bore you with. But so this Audible, these people, they're on to something here, all right? I may not read, but I will listen. Now, you're going to discover thousands of podcasts from popular favorites to exclusive new series. You're going to find guided wellness programs with Audible. You're going to find theatrical performances, comedy, and exclusive audible originals from top celebrities were
才能享受 150 美元的优惠。8 Sleep 目前在美国、加拿大、英国、欧盟部分国家和澳大利亚发货。我毫不掩饰地告诉你们，我们得到了 Audible 的支持，好吗？它是故事的发源地。现在我不是，你知道的，一个伟大的阅读者，好吗？由于种种原因，我就不拿这些来烦你了。但有了这个 Audible，这些人，他们在这方面很有研究，好吗？我可能不读书，但我会听。现在，你将通过 Audible 发现数千个播客，从热门最爱到独家新系列。你将通过 Audible 找到引导式健康计划。你将找到戏剧表演、喜剧以及来自顶级名人的独家 Audible 原创作品、
renowned experts and exciting new voices in audio. The audible app makes it easy to listen anytime, anywhere while you're traveling, working out, walking, doing chores, you decide. All right? Now, for instance, this book, the Suttler Art of Not Giving A Fuck by Mark Manson, this is a potential key to life. It is the, you know, they talk about on the show, the sexy indifference, it is an obnoxious term,
著名的专家和音频领域的激动人心的新声音。Audible 应用程序让你可以随时随地轻松收听，无论你是在旅行、锻炼、散步、做家务，由你决定。好吗？现在，举个例子，这本书，马克·曼森的《不羁的艺术》（The Subtle Art of Not Giving a Fuck），这可能是通往人生的钥匙。它就是，你知道的，他们在节目中谈到的，性感的冷漠，这是一个令人讨厌的词，
but it's better said by Mark Manson here, or better heard on Audible. New members can try Audible for 30 days. Visit audible.com slash smartless or text smartless to 500 500. That's audible.com slash smartless or text smartless to 500 500 that's audible.com slash smartless or text smartless to 500-500 to try audible free for 30 days audible.com slash smartless. When we think of sports stories, we tend to think of tales of epic on the field glory.
但马克·曼森在这里表达得更好，或者在 Audible 上听起来更好。新会员可以免费体验 Audible 30 天。访问 audible.com/smartless 或发送短信 smartless 到 500 500。网址是 audible.com/smartless 或发送短信 smartless 到 500 500，即 audible.com/smartless 或发送短信 smartless 到 500-500，即可免费试用 Audible 30 天。audible.com/smartless。当我们想到体育故事时，我们往往会想到球场上史诗般辉煌的故事。
But the new podcast Sports Explains the World brings you some of the wildest and most surprising sports stories you've never heard, like the teenager who wrote a fake Wikipedia page for a young athlete and then watched as a real team fell for his prank. Diving into his Wikipedia page we turn three career goals into 11, added 20 new assists for good measure. Figures that nobody would, should, have believed. And the mysterious secret of a US Olympic superstar killed at the peak of his career. Was it an accident?
但全新的播客《体育解释世界》（Sports Explains the World）为你带来了你从未听过的一些最疯狂、最令人惊奇的体育故事，比如那个为年轻运动员写了假维基百科页面，然后看着一个真正的球队落入他的恶作剧之中的少年。深入他的维基百科页面，我们将3个职业进球改成了11个，顺便又添加了20次新的助攻。本以为没有人会、应该、相信这种事。以及美国奥运超级巨星在其职业生涯巅峰期遇害的神秘秘密。这是一场意外吗？
Did the police screw up the investigation? It was also nebulous. Each week, Sports Explains the World goes beyond leagues and stats to share stories that will redefine your understanding of sports, and their impact on the world. Listen to sports explains the world, on the Wondery app or wherever you get your podcasts. You can listen to sports explains the world early and ad-free on Wondery Plus. And now back to the show. Kevin, what was that like those first, I don't know, 10 years, because you were just,
是警察把调查搞砸了吗？一切都那么含糊不清。每周，《体育解释世界》都会超越联赛和数据，分享将重新定义你对体育及其对世界影响的理解的故事。在 Wondery 应用程序或你获取播客的任何地方收听《体育解释世界》。你可以在 Wondery Plus 上提前无广告收听《体育解释世界》。现在回到节目中。凯文，那最初的，我不知道，10年是什么感觉，因为你一直在，
you never stopped working and trying and doing shit and like going after it. I'll summarize it. I'll summarize it so that it doesn't take too long. Because we have Scott to go. Well, I know, I know, Sean. I'm gonna get you. I don't want to hold you up too long.
你从未停止过工作、尝试和做事，并且一直在全力以赴。我来总结一下。我来总结一下，这样就不会花太长时间了。因为我们有斯科特要赶。嗯，我知道，我知道，肖恩。我会搞定你的。我不想耽误你太长时间。
You know, everybody asks about the ambition of a guy that comes from nothing. And what you got to understand is if you come from nothing, then nothing is exactly that. So anything that adds up to something is a benefit. So when you keep getting a little bit of something, your ambition grows. When I got a little piece of Hollywood and I got a little piece of success. And a little piece of success was actually getting a flight landing in the room being there for me. That's a piece.
你知道，每个人都会问一个一无所有的人身上有什么样的野心。你必须明白的是，如果你一无所有，那么一无所有就是字面意思。所以任何能够累积成一点什么的成果都是一种福利。所以当你不断获得一点点成果时，你的野心就会增长。当我得到了好莱坞的一小部分，我取得了一点成功。而那一点成功实际上就是搭上了一架飞机，降落并留在那个房间里，对我来说这就是一部分。
I kept adding those pieces together, which you realize is that, was actually getting a flight landing in the room being there for me. That's a piece. I kept adding those pieces together, and what you realized is that, oh, God, it's so much better than what I had. And if it ultimately goes back to where I was, but I was already there, there is no loss. I think about that all the time. You already know what the result is from growing up,
我不断把这些部分拼凑起来，你所意识到的是，其实是搭上了一架飞机，降落并留在那个房间里，对我来说这就是一部分。我不断把这些部分拼凑起来，你所意识到的是，哦，天哪，这比我以前拥有的好太多了。如果它最终回到了我曾经的起点，但我本来就在那里，根本没有任何损失。我无时无刻不在思考这个问题。你从小就已经知道结果是什么了，
so why not try something and fail, and learn from it, because the fallback is already familiar to you. It's your 1,000% correct. I kind of just repeated what you said. Well, you did. You actually did. They do it to me all the time.
所以为什么不去尝试一下然后失败，并从中吸取教训呢，因为退路对你来说已经是轻车熟路了。你这一千个百分点说得对。我刚才基本上重复了你刚才说的话。嗯，你确实重复了。他们总是这样对我。
They cut what I say from five minutes down to about 30 seconds. Well, Jason, take it as a compliment. Take it as a compliment. Before will, you know me. You saw it real younger me. And when you talk about that environment that we were in, I mean, I was a kid. I was a kid and I knew nothing else. So you guys honestly acted as examples of what to do, what not to do, where to go, where not to go,
他们把我讲的五分钟内容剪成了大约30秒。好吧，杰森，把它当成一个赞美吧。把它当成一个赞美。在威尔之前，你认识我。你见证了更年轻的我。当你谈到我们身处的那种环境时，我的意思是，我当时还是个孩子。我当时是个孩子，别的什么都不知道。所以你们老兄老实说，在那个早期娱乐界的世界里，你们成为了做什么、不做什么、去哪里、不去哪里的榜样。
within that world of early entertainment. I got this great, we talked about it when I saw you back in December, I've got this great photo that's now at my house and I've like, Kevin, Seth Rogan, me, Amy, my aunt, I'm gonna go back to the show. I'm gonna go back to the show. I'm gonna go back to the show. I'm gonna go back to the show. I'm gonna go back to the December. I've got this great photo that's now at my house and of like Kevin, Seth Rogen, me, Amy, my ex,
我有一张很棒的照片，我们谈到过，当我12月份看到你时，我有一张很棒的照片，现在挂在我家里，上面有凯文、塞斯·罗根、我、艾米，我的姑妈，我要回节目去了。我要回节目去了。我要回节目去了。我要回节目去了。我要回12月份。我有一张很棒的照片，现在挂在我家里，上面有凯文、塞斯·罗根、我、艾米，我的前妻，
January Jones, Jason Siegel, Nick Stoller, Judd Appetow, in like January 2001. We were just hanging out because we had nowhere else to be. And it was so crazy. I guess who I was. Guess. No. Guess.
詹纽瑞·琼斯、杰森·席格尔、尼克·斯托勒、贾德·阿帕图，大约在2001年1月。我们当时就在那儿闲逛，因为别无去处。太疯狂了。你猜我是谁。猜。不。猜。
I'm not going to do it. Take a guess. You're not going to get me canceled tonight. Say it. Say it. I'm going to make it one more day. I've got questions I've gone over here. There's a cancel proof. All right, you passed that test.
我才不猜呢。你猜一个。你今晚别想让我被封杀。说出来。说出来。我还能再撑一天。我这里还有没问完的问题。这是一个防封杀的考验。好吧，你通过了那个测试。
All right. I'll get you another one. Can I guess you were the black one. There you go. He's gone. Yes. Yes. By the way, you're done, buddy.
好吧。我再给你出一道。我能猜你是那个黑人吗？给你。他走了。耶。耶。顺便说一句，你完蛋了，老兄。
Yes, you're done. You're done. That's right. Now, do your kids recognize and appreciate how hard you work? Are they, do they give it up or are they just like, Dad, like, do they have notes on your phone? No. My kids don't give a fuck about me, man.
对，你完成了。你完成了。没错。那么，你的孩子们认可并感激你工作有多努力吗？他们，他们会表露出来吗，还是只会说，爸，就像，他们手机里有关于你的备忘录吗？没有。我孩子才不在乎我呢，老兄。
My kids are the best kids with no knowledge of, my kids truly, and this is said humbly, my kids have no idea how successful I am. They don't get it. Like, I'm dad. I've seen my kids cry over some people and I've, it's, it's really made me angry. Like, they've met YouTube stars at TikTokers, full tears. Oh my God. Oh my God, Dad, do you know who that is off of TikTok?
我的孩子们是最好的孩子，他们不知道，我的孩子们真的——很谦虚地说，我的孩子们根本不知道我有多成功。他们不懂。就像，我就是爸爸。我见过我的孩子们为某些人哭泣，而且我，这真的让我很生气。比如，他们见过TikTok上的网红，哭得稀里哗啦。噢天哪。噢天哪，爸，你知道那是TikTok上的谁吗？
And I was like, TikTok. That's like, punch to them, punch to the ribs. Well, what happens like you're driving down the street and you're driving by a big billboard with your face? They don't care. They don't care. They say, Dad, you could take a better picture than that. No, my kids are, I make sure my kids are grounded in understanding that that's my job.
当时我就想，TikTok。这简直就像，给他们当胸一拳，肋骨挨了一拳。好吧，那当你开车在街上，开过一个印着你脸的大广告牌时会发生什么？他们不在乎。他们不在乎。他们会说，爸，你本来可以拍一张更好看的照片的。不，我的孩子们，我确保我的孩子们脚踏实地，明白那是我的工作。
So when I'm working, my kids come to my job. I make my kids work on my job. My kids act as PAs. They act as set assistants. they act as set assistants, they act as DA assistants or like lower in craft services. So I make them work. So my kids are here tonight, give me some coffee, would you? I make a word.
所以当我工作时，我的孩子们会来我的工作场所。我让我的孩子们在我的工作场所干活。我的孩子们当制片助理。他们当片场助理，他们当片场助理，他们当导演助理或者做些更基础的制务工作。所以我让他们干活。所以我的孩子们今晚也在这儿，给我拿杯咖啡来，好吗？我让他们干活。
Are they, are they, with the exposure to the business and all that stuff? Are they, are they finding stuff on set that they're really interested in? Do they have the bug? Do they want to get it? My daughter has the bug, she definitely wants to, but I'm an advocate of being a kid, finishing being a kid,
他们，他们，通过接触这个行业和这些乱七八糟的事？他们，他们在片场有没有发现自己真正感兴趣的东西？他们有这方面的热情吗？他们想进这行吗？我女儿有这热情，她绝对想，但我主张做个孩子，先过完当孩子的日子，
and then let's pursue the adult dream. And that's not to say that that's for everybody, that's for me a mouth hole. And my daughter loves that idea. And because of what we've agreed to, when she's done with school, you get the full support and backing of what you took the time to learn.
然后再去追求成人的梦想。这并不是说这适合所有人，对我而言是个开玩笑的说法。我女儿很喜欢这个想法。因为我们达成了共识，等她学校毕业后，你将获得你花时间去学习的领域的全力支持和后盾。
I don't wanna embed them in something at a young age and prohibit them from getting a full extent of that life, like as a child, especially where we are, where we live. It's not the same as when I came up. So they understand that. And I think my daughter wants to do it bad. My daughter wants to be...
我不想让他们在很小的时候就陷进某种事情里，剥夺他们作为一个孩子、尤其是在我们所处的地方、我们居住的地方，去充分享受那种生活的机会。这跟我当年混出头的时候不一样。所以他们明白这一点。而且我觉得我女儿非常想做这行。我女儿想……
Well, Lauren, she wants to act. She wants to act. My daughter wants to act bad. How old is she? I do it at 16. Oh, great. 16 years old. So, Sean wants to act too.
嗯，劳伦，她想演戏。她想演戏。我女儿非常想演戏。她多大了？我16岁开始的。哦，太棒了。16岁。所以，肖恩也想演戏。
Do you? Do you? Do you? Good for you. It's going to happen. It's going to happen. It's going to be tough after this canceling, because you got one coming.
你呢？你呢？你呢？真为你高兴。这事儿准能成。这事儿准能成。经历这次封杀风暴后，接下来可就难了，因为你马上就要挨一记了。
You got to get back up. You think I forgot about that black time. I know Toyota still works. Yeah, exactly. My son wants to be a stuntman. Really? Yeah. What's the stuntman?
你得重新站起来。你以为我忘了我被全网黑的那段黑暗时光了吗。我知道丰田还在合作。对，没错。我儿子想当特技演员。真的吗？对。特技演员是干嘛的？
OK, now I hear that, and I immediately think that he's got like, he's strapped like you. That he's like a snake's under a shirt just like you. Are you guys working out together? Yeah, no. He doesn't have that. So I want to tell you that you're wrong with that assessment. So like, what's not to be creepy, but if you took all your clothes off right now, we're
好吧，现在我听到这儿，我立刻觉得他身材像你一样精壮。觉得他衣服底下像你一样练得像块腹肌。你们俩一起健身吗？对，没有。他可没有那种身材。所以我得告诉你，你对这事的评估是错的。所以，不是想显得猥琐，但如果你现在把衣服全脱了，我们
looking at it. Oh, we're looking at... Again, not to be creepy, right? Not to be creepy, right? Yeah, right. You're basically in bodybuilder shape. Have done for a lot. And that's admirable.
就能看到了。哦，我们就能看到……再说一遍，不是想显得猥琐，对吧？不是想显得猥琐，对吧？对，对。你的身材基本上就是健美运动员的水平。练了很久了。这很令人钦佩。
That takes a lot of discipline. You got a great routine I'm assuming. Yeah, yeah. Here's a thing, man. It's all about the walk away to the bathroom. Right? If you're married every morning, you get up and you go to the bathroom, sometimes naked, sometimes
那需要极大的自律。我猜你有一套很棒的日常锻炼流程。对，对。事情是这样的，老兄。这全在于去浴室时的背影。对吧？如果你结婚了，每天早晨你起床去浴室，有时光着身子，有时
you're just shirt on, sometimes it's not. But that bathroom walk away is always viewed by your partner. And my mind... You're working out a lot on the back of yourself. I'm working on just in general. So, calves, buttocks, and calves, buttocks, back, and lads, all right? I'll let him finish, man.
你只穿着衬衫，有时不穿。但去浴室的那个背影总是会被你的伴侣看到。而在我脑海里……你其实在拼命锻炼你的背部。我只是在进行整体锻炼。所以，小腿、臀部、背部以及背阔肌，好吧？我让他说完，老兄。
You wanna know what a fucking life is? If you finish, man. You are knowing a fucking life, huh? If you walk to the bathroom and you hear subtly, ugh. It will destroy you. So in the back of my mind, I don't ever want to hear that. So when I walk away, I tiptoe, and I make sure that I don't hear my wife go.
你想知道什么才叫他妈的生活吗？如果你说完了，老兄。你知道什么才叫他妈的生活吗？如果你走到浴室，听到一声轻描淡写的“呃”。这会毁了你的。所以在我的潜意识里，我绝对不想听到那个声音。所以当我走开时，我踮着脚尖走，确保我不会听到我老婆发出——
Ugh. All right. Because that means that she's no longer happy with that. So it's all about keeping it in shape. When I walk away, I need you to know, that's what you just fucked. Like that's my, that's my take away, that's it.
“呃”的声音。好吧。因为那意味着她对那个背影不再满意了。所以这一切都是为了保持身材。当我走开时，我需要你知道，那就是你刚刚操过的人。这就是我的，我的心得，就这些。
So now, yeah, I'm just doing the math here. So, if you're walking away from, she's looking at your rear and she's saying, I just fucked that. Take that in I'm just doing the math. Wait a minute. Hold on exactly. Yeah, let's go back. I'm rolling. Let me push it out My my husband understands that good luck. Yeah Oh
所以现在，对，我在这儿算笔账。所以，如果你走开时，她在看着你的背部，然后她说，我刚刚操过那个人。体会一下，我只是在算算账。等一下。等等，没错。对，我们倒回去。我正录着呢。让我表达一下。我，我老公懂这个，祝你好运。对，噢
I love I love a canceled checkmate all right by the way Oh. Oh. Oh. I love, I love a cancel checkmate. All right. By the way, he's off the gett. He's back up. He's no longer on the cancel meter. As back people, we've given him a pass. That's not right, right?
我喜欢，我喜欢一个被封杀的将死局面，好吧，顺便说一句。噢。噢。我喜欢，我喜欢一个被封杀的将死局面。好吧。顺便说一句，他解除封杀了。他又复出了。他不在封杀名单上了。作为黑人群体，我们已经原谅他了。这样不对，对吧？
All right. Now, we've stuck, we've stumbled into a little bit of a segue to, I want one. I want one. I want to ask about this nickname, Chocolate Dropper. Yes. But there's a little bit of a segue to that, right? Well, I don't understand how Sean Sex Life is.
好吧。现在，我们不知不觉切入了一个话题，我想要一个。我想要一个。我想问问这个绰号“巧克力奥利奥”（Chocolate Dropper）的来由。对。但这也顺便引出了另一个话题，对吧？好吧，我不懂肖恩的性生活是怎么样的。
No, no, no. You walk in a way. Okay, now. By the way, the walking away thing I love, because you don't ever look behind you. You just walk away. Oh, you just got to walk away. Yeah, you don't have way, the walking away thing I love, because you don't ever look behind you. You just walk away. Oh, you just gotta walk away. Yeah, you don't have to look, you don't have to be like,
不，不，不。你走开的时候。好吧，现在。顺便说一句，那个走路的动作我太喜欢了，因为你从来不回头看。你直接走开。哦，你只要走开就行了。对，你不用，顺便说一句，那个走路的动作我太喜欢了，因为你从来不回头看。你直接走开。哦，你只要走开就行了。对，你不用回头看，你不用搞得像——
if you ever look back, that's not an insecurity. That's right. Yeah, you don't want to look back. How do you feel, Jason? How do you feel about Amanda's view when you walk away? You look back all the time. You're checking out. Do you walk backwards out?
如果你回头看，那说明你缺乏安全感。没错。对，你才不想回头看呢。你感觉怎么样，杰森？你对阿曼达看你走开时的眼光怎么看？你总是回头看。你在打量自己。你是不是倒着走出去的？
I'm a little bit more of a moonwalk to the bathroom, so. But do you walk backwards just t-shirt and then your shirt cocking? I don't think Jason wears drawers. I think it's just a t-shirt, picking a ass out. Yeah, that's just like. That's how I picture it too.
我更倾向于太空步去浴室，所以。但你是不是只穿着T恤倒着走，然后下半身空荡荡的？我觉得杰森不穿内裤。我觉得他只穿一件T恤，屁股还露在外面。对，就是那种。我脑海里也是这么画面的。
This body showers with a t-shirt on. Winning the poo. Winning the poo is what I pitch you in. Yeah. Just like it is at and the honey. Yeah. But that's called shirt cocking when you're just a t-shirt and then the shirt cocking.
这具身体洗澡时还穿着T恤。小熊维尼。小熊维尼就是我脑海里你穿的样子。对。就像穿着衣服但没穿裤子那样。对。但这就叫“只穿T恤光着下半身”。
Wait, does anybody sleep naked? Do you sleep naked? I'm a naked sleeper. Do you? Yeah. Fuck yeah. Really? Would you keep ballers in clothes?
等等，有人裸睡吗？你裸睡吗？我是裸睡族。你呢？对。他妈的当然。真的吗？你们把猛男塞进衣服里？
Oh no. Are we looking at keep ballers in clothes? Oh, no. Are we looking at your sleep outfit right now? Absolutely. 100%. Absolutely. I'm going 9-9 in between shows in this. Do it. By the way, do some favorite. Don't say 9-9.
哦不。我们在看猛男穿衣服的样子吗？哦，不。我们现在在看你的睡眠套装吗？绝对是的。百分之百。绝对的。我两场演出间隙就这么穿，9-9（指时间/状态）。来吧。顺便说一句，帮个忙。别说什么9-9。
What do you... What do you... Sean, what do you wear? Always the same thing. I wear shorts and a long sleeve loose shirt because Scotty leaves the air conditioning on it, like, what do you wear? Always the same thing. I wear shorts and a long sleeve, like loose shirt, because Scotty leaves the air conditioning on it, like, you know, 20 below. Okay, and what kind of shorts?
你……你……肖恩，你穿什么？永远都穿一样的。我穿短裤和一件长袖宽松衬衫，因为斯科蒂把空调开得像，你穿什么？永远都穿一样的。我穿短裤和一件长袖宽松衬衫，因为斯科蒂把空调开得像，你知道的，零下二十度。好吧，那穿什么短裤？
What shorts? I know. Yeah, because if you wear sweat when the air conditioning's on, and you wear sweat, and then the comforter, it's too hot. So it wears shorts with one leg and one leg out. And then, and then a long sleeve, so you don't have to have the cover on you. It acts as the cover.
什么短裤？我知道。对，因为如果你开着空调穿运动裤，还盖着厚被子，那就太热了。所以我穿短裤，露出一只腿，另一只腿盖着。然后，然后穿长袖，这样你就不用盖被子了。长袖就充当了被子的作用。
Is the one leg out to balance the spinning? Absolutely. What kind of shorts? Are we talking like a thick short? Are we like a flannel short, just because to really maximize, don't look at me like that. Yeah, yeah, what do you mean? What do you mean?
露出一只腿是为了平衡旋转吗？绝对是的。什么短裤？我们在说厚短裤吗？我们在说那种法兰绒短裤吗，为了达到最大舒适度——别那样看着我。对，对，你什么意思？你什么意思？
In a one area where your ass needs to be clean, you sweating it out. You gotta, you gotta flannel short. That's a, you got a flat-o-short. It's too cold to sweat anywhere. Bullshit, that's a flat-o-short. Under a fucking duvet, with a cover, you stink. Well, you fucking stink. You know what?
在一个最需要保持屁股干净的地方，你却在那里狂出汗。你得穿条，你得穿条法兰绒短裤。那就是，你穿了条法兰绒短裤。到处都冷得要死还出汗。胡说八道，那是法兰绒短裤。睡在厚厚的羽绒被底下，盖着被子，你身上会有异味。好吧，你他妈就是有异味。你知道吗？
No, you stain your sheets. Sleeping naked. By the way, by the way, good point, which is why we we going black? Black sheets? I thought about that, Sean. I thought about that. Sean, we just got recanceled.
不，你会把床单弄脏的。裸睡。顺便说一句，顺便说一句，说得好，这就是为什么我们要换成黑色的？黑色床单？我想过这个，肖恩。我想过这个。肖恩，我们刚又被二次封杀了。
It's right canceled. Yeah, I'm back on top, bitch. Anybody who sleeps naked, you're staining your sheets from getting up in the middle of the night and going pee. That's the only thing that's... You're not saying you don't shout. There's a couple drops there. So you're going to have to change your sheets more often. Next question, chocolate drop.
这就叫被封杀了。对，我又重回巅峰了，碧池。任何裸睡的人，你半夜起来去撒尿时都会把床单弄脏。这就是唯一的问题……你别说你不会甩干净。总会有几滴水落下来。所以你得更频繁地换床单。下一个问题，巧克力奥利奥。
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, that is. Who's standing in your sheets? Who's standing in your sheets? Are you keep, love? No, no. Hold on, no, no, he's talking to you. I say, who is Dick is still dripping with my glasses?
等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，那个是。谁把床单弄脏了？谁把床单弄脏了？你是说，亲爱的？不，不。等等，不，不，他在跟你说话。我说，谁的鸡巴还带着尿滴就上床了？
What are you? What are you doing? I'm saying, you don't shake it off enough. Oh my God. I don't have to worry about that because I wear shorts. So wait, Kevin, I don't know if you know this. Jason! Jay-C.
你在干什么？我在说，你根本没有甩干净。噢天哪。我不用担心这个，因为我穿着短裤。所以等等，凯文，我不知道你知不知道这个。杰森！杰尼。
Just in case. Jason back in the day, he would do this thing for a while where he wasn't wearing underwear. When we were years ago shooting a rest of the bell, and this is... Ha ha ha. I think we've told this. I went, I went, I went through a three,
以防万一。杰森以前有一段时间，他有那么一阵子不穿内裤。那是我们多年前拍《Saved by the Bell》的时候，这简直是……哈哈哈哈。我想我们已经讲过这个了。我经历过，我经历过，
I had a three year window where I went commando for some weird reason. So it happened, it happened, it's not that great. And I, and I, and it happened to be while I was working on a show where I wore nothing but khaki pants. So... So he would go to the bathroom, and then what he would do is he's worried about drippage. Oh, good. So...
我有过一个三年的窗口期，出于某种奇怪的原因，我真空上阵。所以事情就是这样，它发生了，其实也没那么好。而且，而且那正好发生在我拍一部戏的时候，我除了卡其裤什么都不穿。所以……所以他会去上厕所，然后他会做的是，他担心会有尿液滴出来。哦，太棒了。所以……
Because you're going to go to the bathroom while we're ready to shoot. But I'm peeing, and so the cameras are going to be rolling. So guess what? I asked before I came here, I said, this is going to be some white boy shit that said no. I asked. Wait.
因为你要去上厕所，而我们马上就要拍了。但我在撒尿，然后摄像机就要开始拍摄了。所以你猜怎么着？我来这儿之前问过，我说，这会不会是什么白男才会干的蠢事，结果他说没有。我问过。等等。
I'm fucking asked. I asked. So he goes, so one day, one day, we're on set. And Jason goes up by one of those, one of the huge garbage cans, and he's standing there,
我他妈问过了。我问过了。所以他说，有一天，有一天，我们在片场。杰森走到那些巨大的垃圾桶旁边，他站在那儿，
and he takes paper, like toilet paper out of his pants, and goes, what are you doing, goes, I gotta put it in there to blot it for like 20 minutes. I gotta wrap it. You wrap it. And then he takes it out in the middle of the set. I'm like, what the fuck are you talking?
他从裤子里掏出纸，比如卫生纸，然后说，你这是在干嘛，他说，我得把这塞进去吸尿吸个20分钟。我得把它包起来。你把它包起来。然后他在片场正中央把它拿出来。当时我就想，你在胡说八道些什么？
That's what serial killers do. I wanna ask, I wanna ask the honest question. I wanna ask the honest question, because I understand the world of producing. I'm gonna get back to the original question. I'm gonna ask the honest question because I understand the world of producing. I'm gonna get back to the original question. So you got to edit point. But before I get there, before I get there,
连环杀手才干这种事呢。我想问，我想问个诚实的问题。我想问个诚实的问题，因为我懂制作这一行。我等会儿会回到最初的问题。我要问个诚实的问题，因为我懂制作这一行。我等会儿会回到最初的问题。所以你有个剪辑点。但在我到达那里之前，在我到达那里之前，
is there ever a good reaction like from the guy that doesn't wear draws? Like what? Like the man that doesn't wear underwear, he pulls out of underwear as a woman ever said, oh, no, I don't. No underwear. Like, what do you think that did?
那个不穿内裤的家伙，有没有过什么好的反应？比如什么？比如那个不穿内裤的男人，他从内裤里掏出纸时，有没有哪个女人说过，哦，不，我不要。没有内裤。就像，你觉得那有什么用？
I don't remember what prompted the... How lazy are you? Like, to not... By the way, it's horrible. It's horrible wearing no underwear. It's horrible wearing boxers. I think boxers, like, they don't bend. They don't stretch.
我不记得是什么促使了……你到底有多懒？居然不……顺便说一句，太糟糕了。不穿内裤太糟糕了。穿平角裤太糟糕了。我觉得平角裤，它们不会弯曲。它们没有弹性。
So I found boxer briefs. Have you guys heard about these boxes? Yes. I don't know. Fantastic. They're incredible. Now, what do you say you sleep naked? Yeah, and you got the onesie.
所以我发现了紧身平角裤（Boxer Briefs）。你们听说过这种短裤吗？听过。不知道。太棒了。它们简直不可思议。现在，你刚才说你裸睡？对，而且你穿着连体衣。
Yes, right. You're naked. But bald. But bald naked. But bald. How do you, how do you, we're gonna, we're gonna wrap up all this crap talk, but. I gave you a cup of wine.
对，没错。你是赤身裸体的。但光着身子。但是赤条条的。但是光着。你如何，如何，我们要，我们要结束这些扯淡的对话了，不过。我给你倒了杯酒。
Do you, do you, pee sitting down? Almost punched you in the fucking face, just then. No. I do. You pee sitting down, right? You're not, see, you're not old enough yet. How old, how old are you? I'm 42. Okay, you're not old enough yet. How old are you? I'm 42.
你，你，撒尿是坐着撒的吗？我刚才差点一拳打在你他妈脸上了。没有。我确实是。你是坐着撒尿的，对吧？你还没，看吧，你还没到那个年纪。你多大，你多大年纪？我42岁。好吧，你还没到那个年纪。你多大年纪？我42岁。
Okay, you're not old enough yet. You, you're peace sitting down, right? Well, I, well, you better not. I don't. I'm a, I'm a, I'm a, you fucking stutter. No. You stutter. You peace sitting down.
好吧，你还没到那个年纪。你，你撒尿是坐着撒的，对吧？呃，我，呃，你最好别。我不是。我是一个，我是一个，我是一个——你他妈结巴了。没有。你结巴了。你撒尿是坐着撒的。
I've been through this for ten. I've been sitting down for years because I think it's rude when like somebody comes over here, like a guy's coming over here, I was like whatever, and they pee and it splashes, and they don't clean it up. So, you know what, guys, just sit down. It takes care of all the splashes. Yeah.
我经历这个已经十年了。我坐着撒尿好几年了，因为我觉得当有人来家里做客时，比如某个家伙过来，不管怎样，他们撒尿会溅得到处都是，而且他们还不清理。所以，你知道吗，各位，干脆坐下来撒。这样就能解决所有溅尿的问题。对。
Yeah. There he is. Uh-oh. And it stretches out your back. Yeah. Your back's gonna start getting tight on you at about 50. And you just say, No, I was gonna make sure I heard it.
对。他就是这样。噢哦。而且这还能拉伸你的背部。对。你的背到50岁左右就会开始变紧了。你刚才说，不，我只是想确保我听到了。
You missed her, you missed her, mate. I know, I fucking heard you. I fucking heard her. You just said so it doesn't splash all around. Yeah, I just sit down. Because a lot of guys are like, I don't fucking care, and then it's just like, and then they walk away.
你漏掉了，你漏掉了，老兄。我知道，我他妈听到了。我他妈听到了她说的话。你刚才说这样就不会到处乱溅。对，我就是坐着撒。因为很多家伙都一副“我他妈才不在乎”的态度，然后就是到处乱滋，然后拍拍屁股走人。
So whoever comes out of my house, I always say, hey, please be neat and wipe the seat. Wait, is there a sign? Do you have a sign? No, but that's a good idea. Ha-ha-ha. All right, come on. All right, wipe the seat. Wait, is there a sign? Do you have a sign? No, but that's a good idea. Ha-ha-ha. All right, come on. All right, so all right, we're out of the bathroom.
所以任何从我家里出来的人，我总是会说，嘿，请保持干净，把马桶圈擦干净。等等，有标语吗？你们有标语吗？没有，但这倒是个好主意。哈哈哈哈。好了，来吧。好吧，擦干净马桶圈。等等，有标语吗？你们有标语吗？没有，但这倒是个好主意。哈哈哈哈。好了，来吧。好吧，那么好吧，我们离开浴室了。
We're out of the bedroom. Hang on. All right, let's get out of the bathroom out of the bedroom. Let's get to the shoe store. Shoesalesman, take me to the shoesalesman days. Oh, back on. No, really? I'm really going to get my ass kicked now.
我们离开卧室了。等一下。好吧，我们离开浴室离开卧室。我们去鞋店吧。鞋店销售员，带我回到当鞋店销售员的日子吧。哦，又开始了。真的吗？这下我真要挨揍了。
I'm going to try. I'm going to try. Because he said, wait, what about, what about? Yeah, I'll let it go. I'll let it fucking go really gonna go back to his kick now. I'm gonna die. I'm gonna die because he said, Wait, what about, what about, I'm gonna let it go. I'll let it fucking go, but I don't like you saying that we're all nasty and pee on the seat. I've never peed on the fuck to see. He's got good hair. I'm not saying, I'm not saying all of it.
我要试试。我要试试。因为他说，等等，那什么，那什么？对，我随他去。我他妈随他去，这下真要挨揍了。我会死的。我会死的，因为他说，等等，那什么，那什么，我随他去。我他妈随他去，但我可不喜欢你说我们都很恶心、在马桶圈上撒尿。我从来没在马桶圈上乱撒过。他头发真好。我不是说，我不是说所有人。
He's got better hair. He's very racist, what he said. He suggested a black people, whatever. All right, let's go. So, will, will, will, had some interesting jobs. Sean's had some interesting jobs. It's had some interesting jobs. They'll hear she's Sailsing she's salesman. What is in your quiver? She's salesman is definitely what I was who I used to be. How long?
他头发更好。他这话说得太种族主义了。他暗示黑人怎么怎么样，管他的。好吧，走吧。所以，威尔，威尔，威尔，做过一些有趣的工作。肖恩做过一些有趣的工作。他也做过一些有趣的工作。听听她以前是卖鞋的，鞋店销售员。你有什么绝活？鞋店销售员绝对是我以前干过的行当。干了多久？
I was a shoesman. She's has been for probably two years. Yeah. I'm very good. I mean We selling sneakers. We sell dress shoes. I saw everything. Yeah. Hasn't had Has that experience made you in your, all your tentacles in your business want to do something with shoes? Because that didn't really. What I want you to do is show. Wait a second, what was that question? Did you say tentacles, what?
我当过鞋类销售员。当鞋类销售员大概有两年吧。对。我非常擅长。我是说我们卖运动鞋。我们卖正装鞋。我什么都卖。对。那段经历有没有让你在你的所有商业触角中，想做点和鞋子有关的生意？因为那其实没有。我想让你做的是鞋子。等一下，刚才那个问题是什么？你刚才说触角，什么？
No, like, with all your businesses going on, I know you probably, you may already have this. You're unthink fuckin' nice, John. It's gonna be tonight and it's gonna be dear diary. Kevin Hart scares the shit out of me. I know. I know. You want to know if he's got a desire to make you guess.
不，我是说，随着你所有的商业版图扩张，我知道你可能，你可能已经有这个了。你真他妈太损了，约翰。今晚过后这绝对能上“亲爱的日记”栏目。凯文·哈特吓死我了。我知道。我知道。你想知道他有没有设计鞋子的欲望。
What did you say? I meant like all your business tend to close. All the businesses that you have going, did your experience being a shoe salesman want to start your own line of shoes? Oh, so you... He's got Sandy. You want to know if all my success within business
你刚才说什么？我的意思是像你所有的商业触角。你手头所有的商业项目，你当鞋店销售员的经历有没有让你想创立自己的鞋类品牌？哦，所以你……他带着沙子呢。你想知道我在商业和各种尝试上的成功，
and endeavors, at some point, if I was like, this should be shoes. He's going to beat your ass. Yeah. Like, heaven-hard shoes. Yeah, got it. That you can pee on. Got it, got it. Maybe the rubber boots. I don't know. Not a white.
到某个阶段，我有没有想过“这应该是一双鞋”？他要揍你了。对。比如，凯文·哈特牌鞋子。对，明白了。那种可以往上面撒尿的。明白了，明白了。也许是橡胶靴吧。我不知道。不穿白色的。
Not a white. Sean has grown on me more and more. I know. Here's a shoe salesman, Tiffany. Shoes salesman showed me the importance of like charisma, charm, right? And in the world of selling shoes, you got a commission of what you sow.
不穿白色的。肖恩越来越让我刮目相看了。我知道。瞧这儿，鞋店销售员，蒂芬妮。鞋店销售员向我展示了个人魅力和吸引力的重要性，对吧？而在卖鞋的世界里，你的提成取决于你的销量。
I mean, money off of being personable and getting people to come back. Oh, God, I can do this. And by the way, I did it because I've really learned about it. So I didn't have acid, I didn't bullshit it, but I didn't think you want to know about a sneaker. Sean, you got a flat foot. That's a flat sneaker.
我是说，通过平易近人和吸引回头客来赚钱。哦，天哪，我能做到这一点。顺便说一句，我做到了是因为我真的去了解了它。所以我没有胡扯，我没有满嘴跑火车，但我认为你不会想了解一双运动鞋。肖恩，你这是扁平足。这是一双扁平足穿的运动鞋。
Bad away, no polythene, or no, actually, actually you do. There's a loo-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-'s all what they were. Pro-Native Sub-Native, no way your foot roll was Jason. I'm just qualified. But yeah, I got it right. Granddad's got orthotics in here. Don't worry about that. Your foot's dead. I do too. So, foot.
顺便说一句，没有聚乙烯，或者不，其实，其实你确实有。这里有个……（模仿鞋垫的各种怪声）……它们就是那样的。原生鞋底，不可能你的脚弓像杰森那样。我没有资格评判。不过对，我猜对了。老爷子鞋里垫着矫形鞋垫呢。别担心这个。你的脚已经废了。我也是。所以，脚。
That's a dead foot. My left toe has been numb for years. But, but you're saying something there, which you, there was a challenge to figure out the customer to see who you needed to be to get the commission that you wanted. It's kind of like acting, kind of changing into the part that job, that job made me realize, oh God,
那是一只废了的脚。我左脚脚趾麻木好多年了。但是，但是你刚才说到了一点，那就是，这里有个挑战，要去揣摩客户，看看你需要成为怎样的人，才能拿到你想要的提成。这有点像演戏，有点像转换成那个角色。那份工作，那份工作让我意识到，哦天哪，
there's something about me that gets people to do the thing that I want. Right. And when I decided to leave that job and pursue the thing that I wanted to do, the person that I had to get to do, the things that my customers were doing with my mom. How do I get my mom to believe in the thing
我身上有一种特质，能让别人去做我想让他们做的事。对。当我决定离开那份工作去追求我想做的事时，我必须去搞定的那个人，就像我的客户对我的妈妈那样。我怎么让我妈妈相信
that I want to do? So the same way I got the customers to believe that this is a shoe for them, I have to take that same cadence, that same quality, give it to my mom. Once I got my mom to believe that thing, oh my God, I'm winning, half the battle is done. My mom believes in me.
我想做的事情？所以就像我让客户相信这是一双适合他们的鞋子一样，我必须把同样的节奏、同样的品质，运用到我妈妈身上。一旦我让我妈妈相信了这件事，哦天哪，我赢了，胜负已定的一半完成了。我妈妈相信我了。
She supports me, but now how do I make money? Now I had to convince the comedy clubs. I can do the thing that I said I would do. Was she, was she, when you said you wanted to be a comic, was she, am I understanding you correctly? She was like, wait, come on, Kevin, really? I mean, no parent-aut the gate is supportive of the, good, you want to be a stand-up, yeah?
她支持我，但现在我怎么赚钱呢？现在我得说服喜剧俱乐部。我能做到我所说的话。她，她，当你告诉她你想成为一名喜剧演员时，我是不是理解对了？她是不是觉得，等等，拜托，凯文，真的吗？我的意思是，没有哪个父母在一开始就会支持这种事，好吧，你想当个单口喜剧演员，是吧？
You know, like, not when you have a different lane as laid out for you, so it was one of convincing. Who were you writing jokes? Like, when you were selling shoes, you were like, already thinking about you wanted to get into comedy, you wanted to be a stand-up, were you writing jokes, were you thinking in that way already? I have never written a joke in my life.
你知道的，当你的生活原本有一条不同的规划路线时，所以这是一个说服的过程。你当时在写笑话吗？比如，当你卖鞋的时候，你是不是已经在考虑进军喜剧界、想当个单口喜剧演员了？你当时在写笑话吗？你当时已经在往那方面思考了吗？我这辈子从来没写过一个笑话。
I've never written a joke word for word. At that point, I had funny stuff that I wanted to talk about. Stories that you could shape and yeah. I had stuff. I'm a person that shapes and molds stuff. Who made you laugh the hardest growing up? That's so funny. In your family, what was your mom?
我从来没有逐字逐句地写过笑话。在那个阶段，我有一些觉得好笑的事想拿出来聊聊。你可以把它塑造成型的故事，对吧？我有一些素材。我是一个喜欢塑造和打磨素材的人。你小时候是谁让你笑得最大声？太搞笑了。在你们家里，你妈妈是吗？
I was gonna say it's not a comic. My dad. Yeah? Not because he was funny, but because he In your family, what you was, you're like, oh, I was gonna say it's not a comic, my dad. Yeah, my dad. Not because he was funny, but because he was so ignorant to what he was doing. My dad had no idea the damage that he calls by giving himself. But it made you laugh like hell.
我本想说不是喜剧演员。我爸。是吗？不是因为他搞笑，而是因为他 在你家里，你是哪种，你当时觉得，哦，我本想说不是喜剧演员，我爸。对，我爸。不是因为他搞笑，而是因为他
It was the funniest thing that ever happened. Look at this stupid motherfucker. No, you didn't think he was stupid. He was just like, I can't believe you said that. Like, my dad, there was a relative that died. My mom's sister, and this is dark, but I'm gonna tell you anyway. My mom's sister died, and we go to the funeral,
对自己的所作所为一无所知。我爸根本不知道他胡言乱语会造成多大的伤害。但那让你笑得要死。那是我经历过最好笑的事。看看这个愚蠢的混蛋。不，你并不觉得他蠢。你只是觉得，我不敢相信你竟然说出这种话。就像我爸，有个亲戚去世了。我妈的妹妹，这虽然有点暗黑，但我还是要告诉你们。我妈的妹妹去世了，我们去参加葬礼，
my dad comes to the funeral, and it's myself, and my mom's other sisters in a circle. My dad comes up in his first words. He was like, we dropping like flies, ain't we? And everybody looked around. He was like, shot his whole brain next, got down. And nobody could say anything, but it was so bad, because they didn't even like him. They didn't like my dad.
我爸也来参加葬礼了，当时我和我妈的其他几个姐妹围成一个圈。我爸走过来，说的第一句话是：我们像苍蝇一样一个个死掉，对吧？然后所有人环顾四周。他就像是，把自己的智商全搭进去了，真是绝了。没有人能说出话来，因为情况太糟糕了，而且她们本来就不喜欢他。她们不喜欢我爸。
He suggested the information as if he was a fan favorite. And he had all, like, and it was a funeral. My dad showed up in, like, white linen at a funeral. He's one of a kind, but I can say for me, that guy, he made me understand humor. Humor sometimes is subjective. My dad has always been subjective. Nobody's ever really liked his approach,
他抛出这个信息时，那表情就像觉得自己是个最受欢迎的人。而且他全身上下，而且那是个葬礼。我爸穿着一身白色亚麻衣服去参加葬礼。他是独一无二的，但我可以代表我自己说，那个家伙，他让我懂得了幽默。幽默有时是主观的。我爸的风格一直都很主观。从来没有人真正喜欢他的路数，
but that's the side that I gravitated towards. And that's what's in me. We'll be right back. In the first part of the 20th century, the Hilton family had a lock on the hotel industry by offering upscaled service at a modest price. The company was expanding fast and buying up iconic properties across the country like the Plaza and the Waldorf Astoria, but their unchallenged rise wouldn't last.
但那就是我所倾向的一面。这就是我骨子里的东西。我们马上回来。在20世纪的前半叶，希尔顿家族通过以适度的价格提供高端服务，在酒店业占据了垄断地位。该公司扩张迅猛，收购了全国各地标志性的地产，如广场酒店和华尔道夫酒店，但他们这种未遭挑战的崛起并不会持续下去。
An ambitious Mormon named JW Marriott decides to pivot from restaurants to hospitality, and he's after Hilton's business, developing modern hotels across the world, but both the Hilton and Marriott families will have to contend with their share of drama in finding a successor, while also fighting to stay solvent in a high stakes business. Hi, I'm David Brown, the host of Wondery's Show Business Wars. We go deep into some of the biggest corporate rivalries of all time. In our latest season, Hilton and Merriott are in a race to expand globally and secure the loyalty of fickle customers.
一个雄心勃勃的摩门教徒名叫JW·万豪，决定从餐饮业转型进军酒店业，他的目标正是希尔顿的业务，在全球开发现代化酒店。然而，希尔顿家族和万豪家族在寻找继承人的过程中都将面临各自的戏剧性事件，同时还要在危机四伏的高风险行业中艰难求生，维持偿债能力。嗨，我是大卫·布朗，Wondery节目《商业之战》的主持人。我们将深入剖析史上一些规模最大的企业竞争。在我们的最新季度中，希尔顿和万豪正展开一场争夺全球扩张以及赢得变心客户忠诚度的竞赛。
Make sure to follow business wars wherever you get your podcasts. You can listen ad-free on the Amazon Music or Wondery app. And back to the show. What was that first time, what was that first time you went on stage and did stand up? What was the venue, what was, do you remember that like, Life House Comedy Club, six people, six people, six.
请在您收听播客的平台上关注《商业之战》。您也可以在亚马逊音乐或Wondery App上免广告收听。欢迎回到节目。第一次，你第一次上台表演单口喜剧是什么时候？那是哪个场地，是什么，你还记得吗，像，生活屋喜剧俱乐部，六个人，六个人，六个。
Six. Wait, what? Life House Comedy Club show, you fucking heard me. Life House Comedy Club. I people. Six. Six. Wait, what? Laugh House Comedy Club showing you fucking heard me. Laugh House Comedy Club. I can love it. Laugh House Comedy Club. Six people. Six people.
六个。等等，什么？生活屋喜剧俱乐部演出，你他妈听清了。生活屋喜剧俱乐部。我人们。六个。六个。等等，什么？笑屋喜剧俱乐部演出，你他妈听清了。笑屋喜剧俱乐部。我太爱了。笑屋喜剧俱乐部。六个人。六个人。
Wow. After God damn comedy club, I go up, I do jokes. They're not laughing, but they're listening. But what I fell in love with was not the people and not the response, but the light. The light didn't deter me. And that's where people buckle. People buckle at the light.
哇。在见鬼的喜剧俱乐部演出完后，我上台讲了笑话。他们虽然没笑，但他们都在听。而我爱上的不是观众，也不是他们的反应，而是那束光。那束光并没有吓退我。而这正是人们崩溃的地方。人们会在强光下崩溃。
You talking about the spot? I'm talking about the spot. No, Jason, I'm talking about the fucking light bomb. I'm the top. Yeah, the spotlight. Yes. The spotlight. That is my kryptonite.
你说的是那个舞台焦点吗？我说的就是那个舞台焦点。不，杰森，我说的他妈的是强光炸场。我才是顶流。对，聚光灯。没错。聚光灯。那就是我的克星。
This is nerve wracking. Being on a stage with a spotlight, I think there isn't one on us. Makes me, I just freeze. No, that's a spotlight. That's an egg crate. It's a 50 by 50. No, it's a modern day spotlight.
这太让人伤脑筋了。站在有聚光灯的舞台上，我觉得上面甚至没有人在看我们。这让我，我直接僵住了。不，那是聚光灯。那是一个50乘50的蛋格网。不，那是现代的聚光灯。
What are you talking about? This is a spotlight. You guys got it up. You said something right now. Everybody's going to get quietly going to listen. Some people freeze, some people don't. Those that don't win, I did not freeze. And granted, I did not get a laugh that night.
你在说什么呢？这就是聚光灯。你们把它调高了。你刚才说了一句话。所有人都会安静下来听着。有些人会僵住，有些人不会。那些没有僵住的人赢了，而我当时没有僵住。当然，那天晚上我确实没得到笑声。
I kept going. And that's what was, that was the thing for me. That was the bug that bit me. And I was like, this is what I want to do. Did you ever have just a wipe out, like a terrible stand-up night? That almost got you to say maybe not? Absolutely. Famous story.
我坚持讲下去了。那就是，那对我来说就是转折点。那就是咬我的那个虫子。当时我想，这就是我想做的事。你有没有经历过彻底砸场、遭遇极其糟糕的单口喜剧之夜？差点让你萌生退意？绝对有。有个著名的故事。
I've told it several times, but I'll tell it again. No, it was. Well, it's new to you, it several times, but I'll tell it again. No, it's new to you, that's what I said I'll tell it again. Thank you, my friend. Um. Um. Uh, I'm in a learning city. I'm doing a joke, and I remember doing a joke
我已经讲过好几次了，但我还要再讲一遍。不，确实是。好吧，对你来说是新的，我讲过好几次了，但我还是要再讲一遍。谢谢你，我的朋友。嗯。嗯。呃，我在一个学习型的城市。我在讲一个笑话，我记得我当时在讲一个笑话，
and the guy stood up and he was like, yes, no, shut the fuck up. Uh-oh. I thought Buffalo Wing got me. Oh my God. By the way, I've never seen accuracy like this in my life. Buffalo Wing hits me. It's me. We're in the face. Little bit of sauce. this in my life. Buffalo wing hits me.
然后有个家伙站起来说，行了，不，闭上你他妈的嘴。噢哦。我以为水牛城鸡翅砸中我了。噢天哪。顺便说一句，我这辈子从没见过这么精准的投掷。水牛城鸡翅砸中了我。砸中了我。砸在脸上。带了点酱汁。这辈子头一遭。水牛城鸡翅砸中了我。
It's me. We're in the face. Little bit of sauce. Get to my eye. Not a lot. Enough to give me a problem where I can't see. I'm like, all right, that's enough. I'm a man first.
砸中了我。砸在脸上。带了一点酱汁。进到我眼睛里了。虽然不多。但也足够让我难受得睁不开眼了。当时我想，好吧，够了。我首先是个男人。
Don't disrespect me. He's like, that's enough. We had enough of you. Get off the stage. Get the fuck off the stage. I'm like, no, I'm going to finish my jokes. And I go to finish my jokes. And the whole crowd, like, oh, no. We don't want you to finish. They were like, boo, I'm gonna finish my jokes. And I go to finish my jokes and the whole crowd,
别对我不尊重。他说，够了。我们受够你了。滚下台去。给老子滚下台去。我说，不，我要把我的笑话讲完。然后我去接着讲我的笑话。结果全场观众，比如，哦，不。我们不想听你讲完。他们开始嘘我，我要把笑话讲完。然后我去接着讲我的笑话，全场观众
like, oh, no, we don't want you to finish. They were like, boo, boo, boo. I got booed. Some other comments were back there. They shook my hand and they're like, yo, you gonna be all right. I was like, yeah, I'll be back next week. They're all playing. I came back next week, same crowd.
就像，哦，不，我们不想听你讲完了。他们开始发出嘘声，嘘，嘘。我被嘘了。后台还有其他喜剧演员。他们跟我握手说，哟，你会没事的。我说，对，我下周还会来。他们都在开玩笑。我下周真的又来了，还是同一拨观众。
I tried to revamp my set the best I could. I go up, I perform. I didn't get booed. I didn't necessarily get big laughs, but I survived this set. And I was the biggest win for me in my life because I came back to the place that's destroying me. So all of my wins, all of my wins in the beginning,
我尽我所能重新整理了我的段子。我上台，表演。我没有被嘘。虽然没得到什么大笑，但我挺过了这场演出。那是我一生中最大的胜利，因为我回到了那个曾把我击溃的地方。所以我的所有胜利，我一开始所有的胜利，
I don't have hero stories. I don't have, oh my god, and they stood up and carried me out. I don't have those stories. All of my wins were mental wins. And a mental wins came from where I come from, where I come from, you beat each other up, we tear each other down, and we destroy the confidence that some don't have.
我没有什么英雄叙事。我没有什么“天哪，他们起立鼓掌把把我抬出去”的故事。我没有这种故事。我所有的胜利都是精神上的胜利。而精神上的胜利源于我的出身，我出身的地方，人们互相殴打，互相拆台，摧毁那些本就不多的自信。
So to survive that, we'll put you in a place of fucking good. Being that I got out of that, I was able to truly grow and really fall into a place where my family got to blossom. And comedy became realistic because I made my city give me a chance. It didn't give it to me. I made them give it to me.
所以能在那种环境下生存下来，会让你变得他妈的非常强大。既然我从那种环境中走了出来，我就能够真正成长，并最终融入一个让我的家人能够绽放光彩的环境中。喜剧之所以变得真实，是因为我强迫我的城市给了我一个机会。它不是白给我的。是我逼他们给我的。
Is there something that legitimately gives you fear? Is it like the health of your family or mortality or, for me, it's bees. Um, I mean, like, is there something that you're just like, that's always gonna be a pet fear of mine that's actually beneficial to you, that keeps you doing what you're doing and doing it well? I think the real fear right now is,
有没有什么东西是真正能让你感到恐惧的？比如你家人的健康、终极宿命，或者，对我来说是蜜蜂。嗯，我的意思是，有没有什么东西让你觉得，这将永远是我心头的一大恐惧，但它实际上对你有益，能促使你继续做好你正在做的事？我觉得现在真正的恐惧是，
is fucking up what's close to being real. You know, I got an opportunity to create generational wealth. I got an opportunity to create and break ground that has yet to be broken for me and mine. For where I come from, you're part of a story that can amplify and propel different types of, I guess you're gonna say like what, and realistic approach to what a dream can really become.
把这个无限接近真实的机会给搞砸了。你知道的，我有机会创造几代人的财富。我有机会为我和我的族群开辟尚未被开拓的道路。对于我出身的地方而言，你是一段能够放大和推动不同类型故事的一部分，我想你会说，比如对梦想究竟能变成什么样子的现实态度。
I'm a part of that. So not accomplishing said goals or not finishing the story, it's not about me, it's about the people that are now are looking at me and oh my God, that's how you do it. So if I don't finish the thing that people are watching that I know I can do, I leave a story incomplete. And success to some is not success to me. It's really giving a true, clear, visual
我是其中的一部分。所以如果没有实现上述目标，或者没有把这个故事讲完，这就不再关乎我个人，而是关乎那些现在正看着我、心想“天哪，原来这就是成功之道”的人们。所以如果我没有完成人们正在看着我完成、而我也知道自己能做到的事情，我就会留下一个不完整的故事。对某些人而言的成功，对我而言并非成功。这真的是给我的出身之地的财富带来一种真正清晰、直观的展现，
into what wealth can be for where I come from, and it doesn't exist. So the fear is that. The fear is not completing that task. Well, and I will say, and I don't mean to embarrass you, but you seem to be doing it in such a graceful, classy kind way. There you have a quality that is so infectious with your vulnerability or humanity.
而这种东西原本是不存在的。所以恐惧就在于此。恐惧在于没能完成那个任务。好吧，而且我要说的是，我无意让你难堪，但你似乎正以一种如此优雅、有品位、温和的方式在做这件事。你身上有一种极具感染力的特质，那就是你的脆弱与人性。
But like, you're not afraid to make a jackass out of yourself. You're never, you're never posturing, you're never playing cool, you're not afraid to be the butt of a joke, and it's so winning, and it's so fun to follow, and get behind, and it's like, I mean, I'd watch you read the phone book. It's just, yeah. I appreciate it.
但像这样，你并不害怕让自己出丑。你从来不端着，从不假装冷酷，你从不怕成为笑柄，这太讨喜了，追随你、支持你是一件多么有趣的事，我就算看你读电话簿我都愿意。真的是。我很感激。
I appreciate it. I appreciate it. Um, it's, I think the dope thing about where we are, and I do say we Well, kind of right. Oh, thank you. Come on, man. Thank you, right? Yeah, me and you you already know where we sit That's right. I think cancer you you then cancel me. All right, we're back on track I Think the dope thing about where we sit is, you know, in this business, we've been putting the position for a long time and believe that we will work for higher.
我很感激。我很感激。嗯，这，我觉得我们现在所处的位置最酷的地方在于——我也确实用了“我们”这个词，嗯，某种程度上对吧？哦，谢谢。拜托，老兄。谢谢，对吧？对，我和你，你已经知道我们坐在哪儿了。没错。我觉得，接着你又把我封杀了。好吧，我们回归正题。我觉得我们所处的位置最酷的地方在于，你知道的，在这个行业里，我们长期以来都被放在那个位置上，并且被灌输一种观念：我们只是拿钱办事的打工人。
And those that have hired us as amazing and dope as those opportunities are and will continue to be, that's all we knew that exists. And now, you know, you're looking in the new era where we can control, we can create, we can do, it's create, we can do. It's different, it's a different agenda. And we're supposed to progress. We're supposed to grow. And the relationships we see in us and our partners
而那些雇佣我们的人——尽管那些机会过去和将来都一样惊艳和酷炫——但这却是我们所知道的全部存在。而现在，你知道的，你正在迎来一个新时代，我们可以掌控，我们可以创造，我们可以去行动，是创造，我们可以去行动。这是不同的，这是一个不同的议程。我们本就该进步。我们本就该成长。而我们与合作伙伴之间建立的关系
are supposed to be coming exactly that partnerships. And when you see that happening, it's, well, how do you become a part of the thing that's the biggest picture? How do you do that? And create opportunities for people to do that. It's like a springboard. So that's the priority for me.
本就应该恰如其分地成为真正的合作伙伴关系。当你看到这种事情发生时，那就是，你如何才能成为宏伟蓝图的一部分？你该如何做到这一点？并为人们创造实现这一目标的机遇。这就像一块跳板。所以这才是我的首要任务。
It's no longer about me. I'm not going to be a bigger star. And I know it sounds like, be a bigger star. I'm not. No, you're at the top of the screen. Yes, it's what it is. Yeah. So for me, it's how do I, and I say that humbly, by the way,
这不再关乎我自己。我不会去追求成为一个更大的明星。我知道这听起来像是在说“要去当个更大的明星”。我不会的。不，你已经站在金字塔尖了。是的，事实确实如此。所以对我来说，该如何，顺便谦虚地说一句，
I'm not. I say, how do I fucking create the opportunity for the next versions to be bigger, to be better? That's the new priority. And if you don't find energy and a new thing, then you sit in the old thing. You get tired in the old thing. You get lazy in the old thing.
我不是。我说，我该他妈的怎么为接下来的版本创造机会，让它们变得更大、更好？这才是新的首要任务。如果你在新的事物中找不到精力和新意，那你就会固守旧事物。你在旧事物中感到疲惫。你在旧事物中变得懒惰。
I don't want the old thing. Do you see, like, is there a moment for you in the future where you see that you've reached enough success or a certain goal where you're like, you know what, I'm good now I can kind of slow down. And we touched on that before. But is there something, is there a goal in mind where like if I can reach that,
我才不要旧事物。你看，未来对你来说会不会有这样一个时刻，当你觉得自己已经达到了足够的成功或某种目标时，你会觉得，你知道吗，我现在挺好的，我可以稍微放慢脚步了。我们之前也聊过这个。但有没有这样一种东西，有没有这样一个目标，如果我能达到它，
I can maybe settle down and calm down a little bit? I think that there definitely is. But I think that for me, that will be very selfish knowing my background. If I go I'm done, I tap out, and I'm just gonna ride out and be good when I have the opportunity to create other opportunities, I think I'm doing a disservice to those
我就可以稍微安顿下来，平静一点？我想肯定是的。但我觉得对我来说，考虑到我的背景，如果我说我做完了，我退出，然后我就这样顺其自然、安于现状，而我本有机会创造其他机会，我觉得我对不起那些
that need a service. So I will much rather, I will much rather provide the Olive Branch where I can. And look, if it happens, and that olive branch is great, and people come and they go through, they go, I did some dope shit, if they don't, at least I tried, and I can say,
需要服务的人。所以我宁愿，我宁愿在力所能及的时候伸出橄榄枝。听着，如果事情发生了，这根橄榄枝很棒，人们来了又走，他们会觉得，我干了件挺酷的事；如果他们没来，至少我尝试过了，我可以说，
that I gave an opportunity for a bigger conversation to be attached to the success outside of me. And that's when she started to struggle with, right? Like, you make money, you get big, you get grown, then you get to go and, oh, wait, well, what else? What else is important? Because it can't just be fame. Is there somebody that inspired you to think this way?
我为超越我自身的成功创造了一个更大对话的机会。这就是她开始挣扎的地方，对吧？比如，你赚钱了，你变大了，你长大了，然后你就可以去，哦，等等，还有什么？还有什么很重要？因为不能只有名气。有没有什么人启发你这样去想？
To be this what your mom. Rest in peace. My mom. Yeah. My mom was always, my mom is a you second those first. And my mom was always always, it's so sad when you look at the people around a person that's happy and those people are unhappy. They're unhappy because a person's happiness is solo.
做成这样，你妈妈。愿她安息。我妈妈。是的。我妈妈总是，我妈妈是“别人第二，自己最后”。我妈妈总是，当你看一个快乐的人周围的人时，会觉得太悲伤了，因为那些人不快乐。他们不快乐，因为那个人的快乐是孤立的。
How does your happiness, how do you spread it out? What are you doing to give that thing out? Where's your energy go? How are you truly implementing it into the lives of others? And it's a conversation that we don't have enough, right? As people, we're very selfish. We're very selfish at times within what we have and what we want to give.
你的快乐如何，你如何把它传播出去？你做了什么来把那东西分享出去？你的精力去哪了？你如何真正把它落实到别人的生活中？这是一个我们讨论得还不够的话题，对吧？作为人类，我们非常自私。有时对于我们拥有什么以及我们想付出什么，我们非常自私。
I don't think that that's right. I think that if I have a high level of happy, if I have a high level of good or information, it's my fucking job to try to give it to those that can benefit off of you. That's my job. Yeah. Right?
我不认为这很对。我认为，如果我拥有高度的快乐，如果我拥有高度的美好或信息，我他妈的职责就是试着把它给予那些能从中受益的人。那是我的职责。对吧？
And I think that people don't key in on that enough that they don't know that actually that is the key to happiness is giving it away. And I don't necessarily assure, but your energy and whatever that is that you have, if you, whatever you put out is what you're gonna get back and that may seem like, well, that's not altruistic because you're just doing it to get a result,
而且我认为人们对此还不够关注，他们不知道其实快乐的关键就是把它分享出去。我不一定能向你保证，但你的能量和无论你拥有的是什么，如果你，你付出了什么，你就会得到什么，这可能看起来像，嗯，那不是利他主义，因为你这么做只是为了得到一个结果，
but you will get such joy if you constantly put that out to other people and make people feel good, you'll end up feeling, and that's the, that's something that I think that people really sleep on. They're not sleep on it, but if you really go and look at some of the, if you go and look at some of the most celebrated, the most celebrated happiest people, right, of our time or before our time, you'll look at their life, they struggle a lot.
但如果你不断地把它带给其他人，让别人感到快乐，你就会收获巨大的喜悦，你最终会感到……我认为这是人们真正容易忽视的一点。也不是忽视，但如果你真的去看看那些，如果你去看看那些最受赞誉的、最受赞誉的最快乐的人，对吧，我们这个时代或之前的时代，你会发现他们的生活，他们其实挣扎了很多。
The things that you think they had, they didn't have, but what they found joy in was providing. Providing it for others people find joy in seeing other people fucking glow and and what we've lost We've lost that so if you look at where we are now This is where battle amongst people because we're trying to control one another We're not allowing each other to fucking flourish and benefit of being who you are We're trying to make you what we want you to be, who we want you to be. I am a fan of joy. I'm a fan of smile, I'm a fan of happy,
那些你以为他们拥有的东西，他们其实并没有，但他们找到快乐的地方在于奉献。为他人奉献能让人在看到别人发光时感到快乐，而我们已经失去了这一点。所以如果你看看我们现在的处境，这就是人与人之间的斗争，因为我们试图控制彼此。我们不允许彼此繁荣并享受做自己的好处，我们试图把你变成我们想让你成为的样子，变成我们希望你成为的人。我是快乐的粉丝。我是微笑的粉丝，我是开心的粉丝，
I'm a fan of love, I always have been. That's what I'm a fan of. So if it's not that, for me, it doesn't work. I tried stand up once, and thank you, thank you. Thank you for asking. And my opening line was, I think I said this on the podcast, my opening joke was, you know, they say ballet is one of the most difficult things you can do, so I say, don't do it.
我是爱的粉丝，我一直都是。这就是我所崇拜的。所以如果不是那样，对我来说就行不通。我曾经尝试过单口喜剧，谢谢，谢谢。谢谢你的提问。我的开场白是，我想我在播客里说过这个，我的开场笑话是，你知道，他们说芭蕾舞是你能做的最困难的事情之一，所以我说，别做。
Well, we just learn. Wow. And we just learn. We just learn sometimes careers can last one joke. Well, I was going to say that. I mean, if we're being real, I'm still waiting for the joke. Well, Sean just showed his white and make it. No, no, there's a lot of different things.
好吧，我们刚刚学到。哇。我们刚刚学到。有时我们发现职业生涯可以只持续一个笑话。好吧，我正想说呢。我是说，说实话，我还在等那个笑话呢。好吧，肖恩刚刚展示了他的白色，让他成功。不，不，有很多不同的东西。
Yeah, this is why I'm royalty. So you're not going to pack up and retire anytime soon. I'm not retiring. Not before your 50. Not before your 50. No, OK. Are you going to squeeze in any more of these great movies of Dwayne Johnson before then?
对，这就是为什么我是皇室成员。所以你不会随时收拾包袱退休的。我不会退休。在你50岁之前不会。在你50岁之前不会。不，好吧。在此之前，你还会挤出时间拍几部道恩·强森这种好电影吗？
Yes. Because it's been really awesome. Now, you guys as close as it seems, because the chemistry is just awesome. You guys think this relationship is so great? My back hurts. Ah! Carry on that guy.
会。因为真的太棒了。现在，你们俩的关系看起来就像真的一样亲密，因为这种化学反应简直太棒了。你们觉得这种关系这么好？我的背好痛。啊！背着那个家伙。
It's tough hurrying that big motherfucker to the finish line is tough. I can be honest with you, DJ and I are very close. That's a really good friend of mine. And our chemistry on screen is the same as off screen. And that's why we've won. We don't go into our trailers in between shots. We're on set, we're on set, and when we work together,
赶着那个大块头冲过终点线可真不容易。我可以对你们说实话，DJ和我非常亲密。他真的是我的好朋友。我们银幕上的化学反应和银幕下是一样的。这就是我们成功的原因。我们在拍片间隙不会各自回到保姆车里。我们在片场就是在一起，当我们合作时，
we truly do work together. And I love the fact that it's been far a few in between because we got something. And we saw each other, we just did a, we got animation movie coming out. With the DC, it's the Superpets. And it's snowballing that? No, it's not snowballing. By the like, can I have some more snowball please?
我们真的是在并肩合作。我喜欢这种合作不常有但每次都有火花的感觉，因为我们搞出了点东西。我们刚看到彼此，我们刚刚做了一部，我们有一部动画电影要上映。DC的，是《萌宠特遣队》。那是滚雪球吗？不，不是滚雪球。就像，我能再来点雪球吗？
By the way, snowballs come but this is a different pet. I want to talk about snowball now because I got to talk about the other pet By the way, maybe the same voice. I'm not confident What I love though is that like we got together we talked man, and we were like We we just got to figure out the next one. But we both know it's never gonna be duplicated. You don't get that thing a lot. And we're very fortunate to have had the opportunity to make the movies that we have. And it must be dope. It must be nice that you've got somebody you're so close with that your escalation in your careers have been very, very, very similar. And you have someone to talk to about what's great about it, what's challenging about it,
顺便说一句，雪球来了，但这是另一只宠物。我现在想聊聊雪球，因为我得聊聊另一只宠物。顺便说一句，可能是同一个配音。我可不确定。不过我喜欢的是，我们聚在一起，聊了聊，然后我们觉得，我们只需要弄清楚下一部该拍什么。但我们俩都知道这是无法复制的。你很难经常遇到那种感觉。我们非常幸运有机会拍了我们拍过的这些电影。而且这一定很酷。你有一个如此亲密的人，你们的职业生涯上升轨迹非常、非常、非常相似，这一定很好。而且你有一个人可以倾诉，聊聊什么是美好的，什么是具有挑战性的，
what's how you're adjusting mentally, spiritually, all of that stuff. I can tell you what though, he's a lot more, DJ's much more grounded. And he's more concrete than I am. Well, because I'm in the shit. I'm in the shit. What are we, I'm in the shit, man. What is that, man? Well, I'm touring, I'm out all the time.
你是如何在心理上、精神上进行调整的，所有这些。不过我可以告诉你，他要成熟得多，DJ比我踏实得多。他比我更有原则。好吧，因为我身处泥潭中。我身处泥潭中。我们在说什么，我身处泥潭中，老兄。那是什​​么，老兄？好吧，我在巡演，我一直在外面。
I'm on the road, off the road. I got the people, I'm dealing with, they're saying he's soft. You're saying he's a diva. No, I'm saying people I'm dealing with. I'm saying he's soft. You're saying he's a diva. No, I'm saying I'm more hands on into the world and more interactive with people on every day. He is from his company side and all of his ventures. But the live entertainment aspect, he's removed from.
我在路上，不在路上。我接触的人，他们说他很软弱。你在说他是个巨星大牌。不，我是说我接触的人。我在说他很软弱。你在说他是个巨星大牌。不，我是说我更亲力亲为地接触这个世界，每天与人们进行更多的互动。从他的公司和他的所有商业投资来看，他是这样的。但对于现场娱乐这块，他抽身出来了。
So remember, the world when he was in wrestling and live performing, that's a different energy. You're given a different energy to people every day. You gotta be on. You gotta be fucking on. He would get off of a wrestler match and then rock, do the things, gotta do the eyebrow. He's gotta take a picture, right?
所以记住，当他还从事摔角和现场表演时，那是另一个世界。你每天都在向人们散发不同的能量。你必须时刻保持状态。你必须他妈的时刻在线。他结束一场摔角比赛后，然后巨石，要做那些动作，得挑眉毛。他得拍张照片，对吧？
Like, I mean, that's me. And then he's gotta eat like 40 chickens a day or something. No, it's like, like, I was like, we were like, and the rocks knew men, you know? Okay, let's hear it, you know? And he's like, it's 30 stakes. I think he's done a great job. He's done a great job at like, you know,
我的意思是，那就是我。然后他得一天吃40只鸡什么的。不，就像，就像，我们就像，而巨石知道，你知道吗？好吧，让我们听听，你知道吗？他说那是30块牛排。我觉得他做得很好。他在以下方面做得很好：
cutting that side off, vituring into his new side. And DJ to business guys is a good dude. And that dude is flourishing. I'm still a little old. He's a sweet guy too. He said the sweet guy. He's a dickhead.
割舍掉那一面，进军他的新领域。对于商人们来说，DJ是个好人。那个家伙现在风生水起。我还稍微有点老派。他也是个甜心。他说他是甜心。他是个混蛋。
He's a dickhead. He's a dickhead. He's not a dickhead. I just want to be on the right. I want him to know that I said he was a sweet guy. Because he's a big dude, as we know. You know, you're doing something like we're doing here. You got a podcast comedy, Goldmines as well.
他是个混蛋。他是个混蛋。他才不是混蛋。我只是想站在正确的一方。我想让他知道我说过他是个甜心。因为他是个大块头，正如我们所知。你知道，你在做像我们这里这样的事情。你也有一个喜剧金矿的播客。
Yes, now, yeah, yeah. Now, is it like a chat show about with comics and talking about comedy and stand up? I do all organic, authentic conversation, right? What are conservatives whatsoever? And I challenge Jason. And I challenge you to do the same thing too. You know, you have to say just like us. You don't need these to you.
是的，现在，是的，是的。现在，这就像是一个关于喜剧演员的访谈秀，谈论喜剧和单口相声吗？我做的是完全有机、真实的对话，对吧？没有任何矫揉造作。我挑战杰森。我也挑战你做同样的事。你知道，你必须和我们一样。你不需要这些……
Well, no. You shouldn't have those, right? Because there's a beauty in the unknown. Mostly just a bounce from my bags. Right, well I get it. I get it. Whether you need them. Whether you need them or not.
好吧，不。你不该有这些，对吧？因为未知之中有一种美。大多数时候只是我包里的存货。对吧，好吧，我懂。我懂。不管你需不需要它们。
Whether you need them or not. What I love to do, I love to actually discover, like I like the fact that I don't know. And when I don't know, I'm gonna ask. And the person has to answer the questions. So as comedians, comedians are dark. Some aren't. Some really have other issues, but you've never heard it.
不管你需不需要它们。我喜欢做的事，我喜欢去发现，比如我喜欢这种未知的感觉。当遇到未知时，我会去问。而对方必须回答这些问题。作为喜剧演员，喜剧演员内心是阴暗的。有些不是。有些确实有其他问题，但你从没听说过。
And the people that you think you love, you really don't know. So on comedy, go mine, you got an opportunity to dive into the minds. Some of your favorite humorous fucking individuals and they say shit to you never thought they would say. Why? Because we have talks and conversations
而那些你以为你很了解的人，其实你根本不了解。所以在“喜剧金矿”上，你有机会深入了解他们的内心。一些你最喜欢的滑稽混蛋们，他们说出的话是你从未想过他们会说的。为什么？因为我们进行的访谈和对话，
that take some of the directions that you never thought that we would go. In conversations in general, that's what we're missing. So, organic, real, driven, transparency, I think that's what people need to see. You need to get back to seeing people be humans and not be programs. So, on comedy goldmines, comedians are actually fucking humans. How often are you doing it? I'm beyond it Jason, whenever I have time. I'm pretty fucking busy, man.
走向了你从未想过我们会去的方向。在一般的对话中，这正是我们所缺失的。所以，有机、真实、由驱动力主导、保持透明，我认为这正是人们需要看到的。你需要回归到看人们表现得像个人，而不是像被编程的机器。所以在“喜剧金矿”上，喜剧演员们其实他妈的都是活生生的人。你多久做一次？杰森，只要我有时间，我就一直在做。我他妈挺忙的，老兄。
You know the schedule keeps changing, buddy. We got nothing. We're going this all the time. Yeah, you know what? We're even traveled with it. Kevin, you know what I love though? You know I love about you. You talk about you're doing all these things But you know at the root of it, you're still the same guy that you were 20 years ago. You have not changed. You're busier, you got more stuff, you had a lot more free time back then, but you're the same dude, and you have that same perspective, that's so, so refreshing.
你知道日程一直在变，老友。我们无路可走。我们一直都在这样做。对，你知道吗？我们甚至带着它一起旅行。凯文，你知道我最喜欢什么吗？你知道我最喜欢你什么吗？你谈到你正在做所有这些事情，但你知道从根本上讲，你仍然是20年前的那个家伙。你一点都没有变。你更忙了，你有了更多的事情，你那时候有更多的空闲时间，但你还是那个老兄，你依然保持着同样的视角，这真的、真的太让人耳目一新了。
That's gotta be the biggest win for you. I think so, and I hope that people that know me, well, I wanna say, I hope, I know, people that know me know that. I think from the outside, the perception is always gonna be different. Like, for example, I've got fucking glasses on now. And I'm gonna be honest with you, I know I look like a dick,
这对你来说一定最大的赢。我想是的，我希望了解我的人，我想说，我希望，我知道，了解我的人都清楚这一点。我认为从外表来看，大家的看法总是会有所不同。比如，我他妈现在戴着眼镜。说实话，
but if I take these off, it's been a, it's been a, it's been a, it's been a, a couple long days. Yes. It's been some long days and I know these eyes are dripping as I'm talking. That's why I'm blocking them. But I think the most, the most important thing for me is, I'm so fucking genuine. Like, I'm so good to the people that know me.
我知道我看起来像个混蛋，但如果我把这些摘下来，这几天真的是，真的是，真的是，经历了好几天漫长的时间。是的。经历了一些漫长的日子，我知道当我说话时这些眼睛在流泪。这就是为什么我在遮挡它们。但我认为对我来说最重要、最重要的事情是，我他妈的太真诚了。比如，我对那些了解我的人太好了。
I really am who I say I am. And when I tell you, like Jason, when he say, Kav, you want to do it, I said, absolutely. It was very fast. It was very fast. I didn't even vet it out. By the way, this could've been some freaky shit. I don't know what to tell.
我真的如我所说的那样。当我对你说，杰森，当他说，凯夫，你想做吗？我说，当然。进展非常快。进展非常快。我甚至都没有去深究背景。顺便说一句，这可能是什么奇怪的破事。我不知道该说什么。
But I didn't vet it out because I'm like, I like to do. I know where it comes from. I remember when we did X, Y, and Z together on Simpson's Solutions. We talked, Jason, you never asked me for nothing. I'm there. That's truly who I am.
但我没有去深究，因为我想，我喜欢做这件事。我知道它来自哪里。我还记得我们以前在辛普森解决方案一起做过X、Y和Z。我们聊过，杰森，你从没向我索取过什么。我在那儿。这才是真正的我。
But it's one. It's just one favor. That's it. Yeah. No, no, no, because this wasn't a bad one. Like, you guys got a good thing going here. You got a great thing. Actually, you have a fantastic thing. You got a fucking crowd full of people that are supporting you guys.
但这只是一个。这只是一个请求。就是这样。对，不，不，因为这不是一个坏的请求。你们在这里做得很好。你们做得很棒。事实上，你们做了一件了不起的事。你们有一群支持你们的观众。
Well, you made it real, real good tonight, and we cannot thank you enough, buddy. And really close you. So go, go. So come in the heart. Thank you, pal. Buddy, thank you, my friend. Thank you, boss. Sorry. Oh my god. Thank you.
好吧，你今晚让这一切变得非常、非常棒，我们对你感激不尽，老兄。真的非常亲密。所以走吧，走吧。所以发自内心。谢谢你，伙计。老兄，谢谢我的朋友。谢谢你，老板。抱歉。天哪。谢谢。
Thank you, boss. Sorry. Oh my god. Oh my god. Thank you, boss. Oh my god. Oh my god. Thank you.
谢谢你，老板。抱歉。天哪。天哪。谢谢你，老板。天哪。天哪。谢谢。
Thank you. Wow. He, uh, he, he did not look back as he was walking away. No, I know. He did not look back. He's confident. Yeah, he's confident. No, I'm not. By the way, great get. Great know. He did not look back. He's confident. He's confident. No, not that way.
谢谢。哇。他，呃，他，他离开的时候根本没有回头。不，我知道。他没有回头。他很自信。对，他很自信。不，我不是。顺便说一句，真棒。真棒，你知道。他没有回头。他很自信。他很自信。不，不是那样。
By the way, great get. Great get. I'm a huge fan. How great was Kevin Kevin? I was going to come in hard. Yeah. He, you know, I meant that what I said, you know, a lot of people get into like a lot of actors are like,
顺便说一句，真棒。真是个好收获。我是个超级粉丝。凯文·凯文有多棒？我本来想说得很强硬。对。他，你知道，我说的是认真的，你知道，很多人进入，很多演员都像，
oh, how do I... I love you. I love you. I love you. They love you. We love him too. What about these guys? No, I said, yeah? Yeah, that's okay.
哦，我该怎么……我爱你。我爱你。我爱你。他们爱你。我们也爱他。这些家伙呢？不，我说，是吗？对，没关系。
Woo! It's okay. I let you know, a lot of... We don't need love. A lot of actors. It's my mother and my sister. Say, stand up. A lot of actors, you know, try...
呜！没关系。我告诉你，很多……我们不需要爱。很多演员。这是我妈妈和我姐姐。说，站起来。很多演员，你知道，试图……
There it is. No, that doesn't matter. Yeah! I love you too. All right, so coming up. No, no matter, no matter. Yeah. I love you, too. All right, so coming up. So a lot of actors, you know, try to get it. A lot of actors try to get into other facets of the business
就是这样。不，那没关系。耶！我也爱你。好吧，那么接下来。不，没关系，没关系。耶！我也爱你。好吧，那么接下来。所以很多演员，你知道，试图去尝试。很多演员试图涉足商业的其他领域，
because you realize you have to diversify. And he's such a huge inspiration to so many people who are just like maybe stuck just doing one thing as neck. Like, how can I follow Kevin Hart, man? Everything read up on him. How he did it is just so inspiring it's amazing to me yeah it's incredible and and I meant it that he is quite quite literally just the same dude he's so he's got his feet on the ground and he's of course he's just flying at such a different altitude now but but but maintaining that sort of that same sense of himself is pretty good. He's got
因为你意识到你必须多元化。对于许多可能卡在只做一件事上的粉丝来说，他是一个巨大的灵感来源。就像，我怎么才能追随凯文·哈特呢，老兄？阅读所有关于他的资料。他是怎么做到的，简直太鼓舞人心了，太让我惊叹了。是的，太不可思议了。而且我是认真的，他真的、真的就是同一个人，他的双脚依然踩在地上，当然他现在飞在完全不同的高度上，但但但能保持那种最初的自我感觉，真的很不错。他拥有
all this still and he's does all that. He's just got time to work out. I mean, he's huge. He's like, he's almost like he's... Bye, all of it! Woo! Bye, bye, bye, you smart. Hi, you smart. Smart.
这一切依然还在，他做着所有这一切。他只是有时间去健身。我的意思是，他太壮了。他简直就像，他几乎就像是……再见，所有人！呜！再见，再见，再见，你真聪明。嗨，你真聪明。聪明。
Smart. Smart. Flush. SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Michael Grant Terry, Rob Armjarve, and Bennett Barberco. Smart. Last. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
聪明。聪明。流畅。SmartLess 由 Michael Grant Terry、Rob Armjarve 和 Bennett Barberco 100% 有机手工制作。Smart。Less。这个节目还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。